I am 50 years old and do you know what I don't want to do on my vacations anymore? Oh probably a few things. I don't want to cram my family into the same one bedroom room and bathroom. I don't want to. No. I don't want us all on top of each other. I want my own bedroom separate from the children, which is why I prefer Airbnb. Because we can all have our space, and then it's like, makes the whole vacation more relaxing. We can go to bed at different times. You know, I can stay up and read,
我50岁了，你知道我在度假时最不想做的事是什么吗？哦，大概有那么几件。我不想把我们一家人挤在同一个一居室的房间和浴室里。我不想。不。我不想让我们所有人都挤在一起。我想要有自己的卧室，和孩子们分开，这就是为什么我更喜欢Airbnb。因为我们都可以拥有自己的空间，然后这会，让整个假期更轻松。我们可以不同时间睡觉。你知道的，我可以留下来看书，
or more likely these days, I go to bed before everybody else. You know what I love about Airbnb? What? Snacks. You have what I love about Airbnb? What? Snacks. You have a fridge, you have a kitchen. So I'm not calling up room service constantly and having to pay that fee.
或者现在的可能性更大，我在所有人之前就上床睡觉。你知道我最喜欢Airbnb的什么吗？什么？零食。你有什么我最喜欢Airbnb的？什么？零食。你有一个冰箱，你有一个厨房。所以我不用一直打电话叫客房服务还要支付那笔费用。
I'm just like, hey, we pack snacks, they're in the fridge, go get them. Well, everyone, consider Airbnb for your next adventure. You won't regret making the switch from a traditional hotel. I'm Jenna Fischer. and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you.
我只会想，嘿，我们带了零食，都在冰箱里，去拿吧。好了，各位，为你们的下一次冒险考虑一下Airbnb吧。改住传统酒店绝对不会让你后悔。我是詹娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正为你带来终极的办公室爱好者播客。
Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details and lots of VFF stories. We're the Office Ladies 6.0. Hi there. Hello. Hey, so today on Office Ladies, we have a very special interview
每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和大量VFF（挚友）故事，更深入地探寻《办公室》的世界。我们是6.0版办公室辣妈。大家好。嗨。嘿，那么今天在办公室辣妈节目中，我们有一个非常特别的访谈
with the person I call the architect of the office. It is our editor and director, Dave Rogers. I like how you just jumped right in with it today, Ange. What is happening in the new year? Are you becoming me? I think so. Because look, I'm taking us on a tangent. Should I read my diary, my journal?
采访对象是我称之为《办公室》建筑师的人。他就是我们的剪辑师兼导演戴夫·罗杰斯。我喜欢你今天直接切入正题的方式，安吉。新的一年发生了什么？你在变成我吗？我想是的。因为看吧，我又开始扯远了。我是不是该读读我的日记，我的日志？
And I'm just like, let's get to it. I feel like I want to. I want to. What's happened this year? I don't know. I feel like my 2025 mantra is let's get to it. Okay. Well, let's get to it. Okay. Well, let's get to it then.
我只想说，我们切入正题吧。我觉得我想这么做。我想。今年发生了什么？我不知道。我觉得我2025年的座右铭就是：直接切入正题。好吧。好吧，那我们就切入正题吧。好吧。好吧，那我们就切入正题吧。
Dave Rogers worked on The Office from 2005 to 2013. He started as our editor, but then, as you all know, he started directing in season five. In total, Dave edited 95 of the original broadcast episodes and he directed eight of them. He knows the show better than anyone. Well, Angela, I guess you are going to share some digital clutter with us now.
戴夫·罗杰斯在2005年至2013年期间参与了《办公室》的工作。他最初是我们的剪辑师，但正如大家所知，他后来在第五季开始执导。戴夫总共剪辑了95集原版播出剧集，并执导了其中的8集。他对这部剧的了解比任何人都多。好吧，安吉拉，我想你现在要跟我们分享一些数字杂物了。
So you are staying in your wheelhouse in a way. I'm a combo. Oh, it's combo gear. It's combo gear. Yeah, I'm a combo platter. 2025 is let's get to it, but also let's chat a little bit. I'm really liking this. So I did share with Jenna
所以你在某种程度上还是留在你的擅长领域里。我这是个组合。哦，这是个组合大礼包。这是个组合大礼包。对，我是一个拼盘。2025年的座右铭是直接切入正题，但也要稍微闲聊一下。我真的很喜欢这样。所以我确实跟詹娜分享过
that I found something pretty fun in my digital clutter, and I'm excited to share it with you all. So I have talked about this before on the podcast. Years ago, when the show was on the air, I teamed up with the NBC digital folks with Joya and Scott and Carol, all those folks, they're awesome. And we did a little series for the website called Adventures with Angela.
我在我的数字杂物里发现了一些挺有趣的东西，我很高兴能和大家分享。所以我以前在播客里谈过这个。多年前，当这部剧还在热播时，我和NBC数字团队的乔伊娜、斯科特、卡罗尔以及所有那些伙伴们合作过，他们太棒了。我们为网站制作了一个名为《安吉拉大冒险》的小系列节目。
They were so cute. They are all these videos. If you kind of showing different aspects of the show, you would introduce different actors or different crew members. And you sent me this one, Angela. It's cute, Patoot. Galore. I had so much fun doing these. They're just little behind the scenes of life on the set of The Office. Well, the one I sent Jenna was the week I went into Dave's editing bay. We found the footage. I thought it would be so fun to hear it.
它们太可爱了。全都是这些视频。如果你从某种角度展示这部剧的不同方面，你会介绍不同的演员或不同的剧组人员。而你把这个发给了我，安吉拉。真是可爱至极。太可爱了。制作这些节目我玩得太开心了。它们只是《办公室》片场生活的幕后花絮。好吧，我发给詹娜的那段是我去戴夫剪辑室的那周。我们找到了这段素材。我觉得听到它一定会非常有趣。
I'm going to share it in stories as well. And it just took us right back. Hello NBC.com. We have a behind the scenes exclusive with Dave Rogers, one of our fabulous editors on the show. That's Dave. It's also Donut Cart Day. Mini donuts! It's ridiculous. Did you get any? I did not. Not yet. You want one?
我也会把它分享到快讯里。这直接把我们带回了过去。你好，NBC.com。我们有关于戴夫·罗杰斯的幕后独家花絮，他是我们剧里超级棒的剪辑师之一。那是戴夫。这也是甜甜圈车日。迷你甜甜圈！太荒谬了。你拿到了吗？我没有。还没有。你想来一个吗？
Yeah. They're so good. I'll take one. Dave Rogers worked on The Single Guy, Seinfeld, wow, news radio, Entourage. Wow, I got a whole file over here. Do you have any Entourage stories? Come on, those guys, they're wild, they're crazy, right? I was in an edit bag far away from all the locations that they shoot on the show. He's in line, editors know everything.
好吧。它们太好吃了。我要一个。戴夫·罗杰斯曾参与过《单身男子》、《宋飞传》、哇，新闻广播》、《明星伙伴》。哇，我这里有一整份档案。你有什么《明星伙伴》的故事吗？拜托，那些家伙，他们很狂野，他们很疯狂，对吧？我当时在一个远离他们拍戏地点的剪辑室里。他在排队，剪辑师无所不知。
I'm absolutely sure. You hear everything. They hear everyone's conversations. Okay. You've been with the office since the pilot. I came on right after the pilot. I tweaked a little bit in the pilot. This isn't right. You gave me the wrong thing. Before we broadcast. Dave was a first time director this season, you guys. It was really awesome. Thank you. Thanks.
我绝对确信。你们什么都听得到。他们能听到每个人的对话。好吧。你从试播集开始就参与《办公室》了。我在试播集之后马上就加入了。我在试播集里稍微调整了一下。这不对。你给我的东西不对。在我们播出之前。戴夫这季是第一次当导演，伙计们。真是太棒了。谢谢。谢谢。
You know the show so well. I have to say, I'm pretty blown away by it. I mean, because he sort of sits here and watches take after take after take. I do. One thing I'm learning right here and now is that the editor's room? Little toasty. Yeah. Little toasty. Can we talk about your desk for a second?
你对这部剧太了解了。我必须说，我真的很为之惊叹。我是说，因为他基本上就坐在那里，一遍又一遍地看一条又一条的镜头。我确实是。此时此刻我学到的一件事是：剪辑室？有点热。对。有点热。我们能聊聊你的桌子吗？
Yeah. Yeah, let's talk about my desk. Who's this guy? That's Bryce. Bryce! Yeah. He's so cute. Sometimes he comes in.
可以。可以，我们来聊聊我的桌子。这货是谁？那是布莱斯。布莱斯！对。他太可爱了。有时他会进来。
I almost brought him in today because I knew you were coming in and as a tribute to you in the Super Bowl episode Having your little cat bandit. You're gonna have Bryce in the drawer. Well Bryce here, you can swing this way. This is where Bryce Oh my god. He does hang out in the closet. He's got a little bed and I've got stuff food and toys. I wonder if you were the inspiration for that high-tech stuff here. I want to touch all the knobs. Yes. No product placement.
我今天差点把他带来了，因为我知道你要来，以此向你在超级碗那一集里有你的小猫强盗致敬。你会把布莱斯放在抽屉里。嗯，这边的布莱斯，你可以这样转过来。这就是布莱斯。哦，天哪。他确实会在壁橱里闲逛。他有个小床，我还有杂物、食物和玩具。我想你是不是那些高科技玩意的灵感来源。我想摸摸所有的旋钮。是的。没有植入式广告。
What are we talking about here? Do we have dry skin? Yes. You can feel how warm and dry this room is. It is very warm in here. So I try to keep moisture up. You try to keep moisture up. Yes.
我们在说什么呢？我们皮肤干燥吗？是的。你能感觉到这个房间有多暖和多干燥。这里面真的很暖和。所以我尽量保持湿度。你尽量保持湿度。是的。
I never used to, but then the ladies are always like, your hand feels like an alligator. So much information. I don't want to know what the ladies say. What does this mean right here? What's this? but then the ladies are always like, your hand feels like an alligator, so. Too much information. I don't want to know what the ladies say. What does this mean right here? What's this?
我以前从不这样，但后来女士们总是说，你的手摸起来像短吻鳄。信息量太大了。我不想知道女士们是怎么说的。这到底是什么意思？这是什么？但后来女士们总是说，你的手摸起来像短吻鳄，所以。信息量太大。我不想知道女士们是怎么说的。这到底是什么意思？这是什么？
Those are technical things. Can I tell you, this looks like something that would be in Lost, and that they would show for like a whole season and then say it means nothing. That picture of Dean, that's our other editor, Dean Holland. Yes. And Dave, and they won an Emmy for our show, which was amazing. It was the episode, The Job.
那些是技术方面的东西。我跟你说，这看起来就像《迷失》里会出现的东西，而且他们会演上一整季，然后说这毫无意义。迪恩的照片，那是我们的另一个剪辑师，迪恩·霍兰德。是的。还有戴夫，他们为我们的节目赢得了一座艾美奖，这太棒了。就是那一集，《工作》。
Jenna and I presented at the Eddie Awards, when you guys won. Right. For the Academy of Cinema Editors. Yes. And we got a big laugh, because Jenna talked about, like, an editor's room being dark and sweaty. And I said that it's the place where this noise comes from. Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry's the place where this noise comes from.
当你们获奖时，我和詹娜在艾美奖（Eddie Awards）上颁奖。没错。为美国电影剪辑师工会。是的。我们引得哄堂大笑，因为詹娜谈到了像剪辑师的房间又黑又闷。我说过这是这种声音传出来的地方。抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉是这种声音传出来的地方。
Thank you. Oh, big laughs. The editors were going crazy. Here, I'll show you what that sounds like. I should be on Saturday night live. I can do my rewind, girl. Angela, we can't write a skit for that. Really? Because it's gold. Angela, these are amazing. You are an amazing interviewer.
谢谢。哦，引得大笑。剪辑师们都快疯了。来，我给你们听听那是什么声音。我应该去参加《周六夜现场》。我能发出倒带女孩的声音。安吉拉，我们不能为那个写剧本。真的吗？因为这是黄金素材。安吉拉，这些太棒了。你是一个出色的采访者。
You discussed mini donuts, moisturizing his hands, the knobs in the room. I just went through his office and pointed out everything on his desk. Poor Dave, he's such a good sport. He did show me the closet where his dog Bryce would hang out. I loved Bryce. Bryce had a bed, a blanket, a toy, he had a water bowl, food. He was very cozy in Dave's office. And then I didn't realize that while talking to Dave, I threw shade at Entourage and lost. I loved it.
你讨论了迷你甜甜圈、给他的手保湿、房间里的旋钮。我刚刚走过他的办公室，指出了他桌子上的每样东西。可怜的戴夫，他太有体育精神了。他确实带我看了他狗布莱斯闲逛的壁橱。我很喜欢布莱斯。布莱斯有一张床、一条毯子、一个玩具，他有一个水碗、食物。他在戴夫的办公室里非常惬意。然后我没有意识到，在和戴夫交谈时，我暗中讽刺了《明星伙伴》和《迷失》。我很喜欢。
I thought it was a great interview. It's a horrible interview, but it was really fun hanging out with Dave in his editing bay. I miss those days. Well, you definitely have to post that video on our stories because it's really fun to see as well. I feel like I was there because he was editing Pam during this interview so I'm up on the screen it was really cool. I mean I do have a really good rewind voice I really do. You do? The first time you hear it that's me not
我觉得这是一个很棒的采访。这是一个糟糕的采访，但和戴夫一起在他的剪辑室里闲逛真的很有趣。我很怀念那些日子。好吧，你绝对必须把那段视频发到我们的快讯上，因为看它也真的很有趣。我觉得我就在那里，因为他在这次采访中正在剪辑帕姆，所以我出现在屏幕上，这真的很酷。我是说，我确实有一个非常棒的倒带声音，我真的有。你有吗？你第一次听到的时候，那是我，不是
the computer. Yeah and the second time is the computer. I know. It's like which one's which. You don't know should I do it right now? Please of course. It's like which one's which? You don't know, should I do it right now? Please, of course. Okay. It's so good. That was Angela, that wasn't Sam. Mm-hmm. No. That was me. Okay, well one thing is for sure, Dave is the Office Encyclopedia,
电脑。对，第二次是电脑。我知道。就像哪个是哪个。你不知道，我现在该做吗？请吧，当然。就像哪个是哪个。你不知道，我现在该做吗？请，当然。好的。太棒了。那是安吉拉，不是萨姆。嗯哼。没有。那是我。好吧，有一件事是肯定的，戴夫是《办公室》的百科全书，
and he is here with us today in studio to talk about how he has taken on the very big task of assembling all of the Office super fan episodes on Peacock. I loved our conversation with him because you can really hear how much he cares about the legacy of the Office. Yeah. Dave, along with his team of editors,
他今天和我们一起在录音室里，谈论他是如何承担起将Peacock上的所有《办公室》超级粉丝集结在一起这一极其艰巨的任务的。我很喜欢我们与他的对话，因为你真的能听到他是多么关心《办公室》的遗产。是的。戴夫和他的剪辑师团队，
are being so thoughtful about these super fan episodes. Yeah, I mean, he shares how they decide what footage to add. And he also, I mean, my gosh, he told us so many treasures that he found while putting these together. It's such a great conversation. Yeah. Dave has been working on these superfan episodes for years. He is now all the way up to season eight and you can find them on Peacock. Oh, and one last thing. We also talked with Dave just a little bit
对这些超级粉丝集非常用心。是的，我是说，他分享了他们是如何决定添加哪些素材的。而且他还，天哪，他告诉了我们他在拼凑这些时发现的那么多宝藏。这真是一次很棒的对话。是的。戴夫多年来一直致力于这些超级粉丝集的制作。他现在一直做到了第八季，你可以在Peacock上找到它们。哦，还有最后一件。我们还跟戴夫聊了一会儿
about the new spinoff show, The Paper. He is working on that as well. So that was fun. Yeah, I know. I can't wait till he can share more about it. I know, and we can share more about it. Our visit. All right, well, we hope you enjoyed this as much as we did.
关于全新的衍生剧《纸业公司》。他也在参与那个项目。所以那很有趣。对，我知道。我等不及他能分享更多相关信息了。我知道，我们可以分享更多。我们的访问。好吧，好吧，希望你们和我们一样喜欢这个节目。
We're gonna take a quick break and be back with our interview with Dave Rogers. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. Every January is a time when I feel like we all reflect. You know, you can really do it any time of the year, but I think, you know, you do feel that reset. You do. It's like you have 365 blank pages ahead of you just waiting to be filled and you can
我们要稍作休息，回来后继续播放对戴夫·罗杰斯的采访。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。每到一月份，我都觉得我们所有人都会反思。你知道，你其实可以在一年中的任何时候这样做，但我认为，你知道的，你确实能感受到那种重置。确实。就像你面前有365张空白的页数正等着被填满，而你可以
decide how to do that. I'm so poetic, Angela. Oh, really? Thanks. 365 blank pages. Well, I might have had some help. All right. Well, I'm going with your book metaphor.
决定如何去做。我太有诗意了，安吉拉。哦，真的吗？谢谢。365张空白页。好吧，我可能得到了一些帮助。好吧。好吧，我借用一下你的书的隐喻。
Okay. You could think of therapy with your book metaphor. Okay. You could think of therapy as your editorial partner, helping you to write these new chapters and create the meaningful story that you deserve to live. How do you like that? I really like it a lot. BetterHelp is fully online and making therapy affordable and convenient, serving over 5 million people worldwide. It has a diverse network of more than 30,000 credentialed therapists with a wide range of specialties. And you can switch therapists at any time at no extra cost.
好的。你可以把心理咨询当作你的编辑伙伴，帮助你书写这些新章节，并创造你理应拥有的有意义的人生故事。你觉得这个怎么样？我真的很喜欢。BetterHelp完全在线，让心理咨询负担得起且方便，为全球超过500万人提供服务。它拥有一个由30,000多名持有执照、拥有广泛专业特工的心理咨询师组成的多元化网络。而且你可以随时更换咨询师，无需额外费用。
Write your story with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com slash office ladies today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies. Hey, I'm Ben Stiller. I'm Adam Scott. And we make a TV show called Severance. On January 17th, Severance is back for season two on Apple TV Plus. And we can't wait for you guys to see it. And before the premiere, Ben and I are going to be binging season one and putting out daily recap podcasts.
用BetterHelp书写你的故事。今天就访问 BetterHelp.com 斜杠 office ladies，首月即可享受九折优惠。网址是 BetterHelp，H-E-L-P 点 com 斜杠 office ladies。嘿，我是本·斯蒂勒。我是亚当·斯科特。我们制作了一部名为《人生切割术》的电视剧。1月17日，《人生切割术》第二季将在Apple TV Plus上回归。我们迫不及待地想让你们看到它。在首播之前，我和本将狂刷第一季，并推出每日回顾播客。
Yep, each weekday beginning January 7th, we'll be dropping an episode featuring exclusive behind-the-scenes tidbits and brilliant insights from our cast and crew and us. Patricia Arquette, Britt Lauer, Zach Cherry, John Totoro, the list goes on. All your favorite Lumen employees, their friends, families, enemies in your feed every single weekday. And here's the best part, after that we're going to keep going. Tune in weekly as we recap every episode of season two. The podcast drops on the same day the episode comes out. It's the Severance podcast with Ben and Adam on Apple podcasts, the Odyssey app, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hi, Dave Rogers. Hello. How are you guys doing?
没错，从1月7日开始的每个工作日，我们都会发布一集，其中包含独家幕后花絮以及来自我们演员、剧组和我们自己的精彩见解。帕特里夏·阿奎特、布里特·洛尔、扎克·切利、约翰·特托罗，名单不胜枚举。你所有最喜欢的卢蒙员工、他们的朋友、家人、敌人，每个工作日都会出现在你的订阅源中。最棒的是，在那之后，我们会继续下去。每周收听我们对第二季每一集的复盘。播客与剧集在同一天发布。这就是本和亚当主持的《人生切割术》播客，在Apple Podcasts、Audacy应用程序或你获取播客的任何地方收听。嗨，戴夫·罗杰斯。你好。你们最近怎么样？
It is so fun to have you in our studio. I'm just doing like this air hug across the table because I'm so happy to see your face. You have contributed so much to Office Ladies, but like now here you are in person. It's such a treat. Thank you. It's great to be here. It's great to see both of you.
很高兴你能来到我们的录音室。我只是隔着桌子做了一个隔空拥抱，因为我太高兴看到你的脸了。你为“办公室辣妈”做出了如此巨大的贡献，但现在你居然亲自来到了这里。这真是一种享受。谢谢。很高兴能来到这里。很高兴见到你们两个。
Yeah, listen, I love the office. I love the office ladies. So. Yay. Dave listens to the podcast, and he will email us the most lovely email saying, hey, you guys really crushed that one or great details. It really means a lot to us, Dave, because no one knows the show better than you.
是的，听着，我喜欢《办公室》。我喜欢“办公室辣妈”。所以。太棒了。戴夫会听这个播客，他会给我们发一封最可爱的电子邮件，说，嘿，你们那一集真的做得很棒，或者细节很棒。这对我真的很重要，戴夫，因为没有人比你更了解这部剧了。
That's the truth. Thank you. That's high praise. A lot of pressure. But I do feel like I'm still living the show. And these super fan episodes have brought it all back where I'm back into my original projects, editing projects, and watching all the old cuts and putting some deleted scenes in and some new material that no one's ever seen before. Yeah.
那是真的。谢谢。这是极高的评价。压力很大。但我确实觉得我还在经历这部剧。这些超级粉丝集把这一切都带回来了，我又回到了我的原创项目、剪辑项目中，看着所有旧的剪辑版本，并加入了一些从未有人见过的删减片段和新素材。是的。
I mean, how did this come to be? Like, when did they first approach you about creating these superfan episodes? Do you remember that conversation? Yeah, I was on a phone call with Greg Daniels, and I think Howard Klein was on the call, and some of the NBC Peacock executives. And I think, I'm not sure if it tied in exactly when Peacock executives. And I think, I'm not sure if it tied in exactly when Peacock, the streaming site, was starting or if it was just something that they had bought the office
我是说，这到底是怎么开始的？就像，他们是什么时候第一次找你创作这些超级粉丝集的？你还记得那次谈话吗？是的，我当时正在和格雷格·丹尼尔斯通电话，我想霍华德·克莱因也在电话里，还有一些NBC Peacock的高管。我想，我不确定这是否与Peacock，也就是流媒体网站开始的时候正好吻合，还是只是他们买下了《办公室》的某项资产
and then that was gonna launch. And so we were discussing all the goodies that we could give them. And I mean just like, we used to pack our DVDs with so many things. We had behind the scenes videos. We had like Jenna's Booze Cruise video. We had bloopers, webisodes, the accountants.
然后就要上线了。所以我们当时在讨论我们可以给他们的所有好东西。我的意思是，就像，我们以前的DVD里塞满了各种东西。我们有幕后视频。我们有詹娜的酒船视频。我们有笑场片段、网络剧、《会计师》。
You know, I mean like just, you know, we had all this great material. A lot of times, you know, people like they're just discovering it now. Like they never, they didn't watch the DVDs or they were, you know, kind of got onto the show after the DVDs were a thing and only watched it on streaming, on Netflix or on, you know, cable. And so, you know, I said, oh, this would be great to have a place to put all of this stuff. Like to, you know, just, we've shot promos
你知道，我的意思是，就像，你知道，我们有所有这些伟大的素材。很多时候，你知道，人们就像是他们现在才发现这些。比如他们从未看过DVD，或者他们是在DVD流行之后才接触到这部剧，只在流媒体上观看，在Netflix上或者在有线电视上。所以，你知道，我说，哦，能有一个地方把所有这些东西都放进去会很棒。就像，你知道，我们拍摄了宣传片
that were like full scenes. We would do for the Olympics, you know? We would do stuff for just various like the Super Bowl and even the more you know parodies that we did. Yes. That were, that these were great. And these aired on NBC during the day when the show was on.
就像完整的场景一样。为了奥运会，你知道的，我们会拍。我们甚至会为各种像超级碗这样的活动做一些事情，甚至还有我们做过的“你知道得更多”的恶搞短片。是的。这些都很棒。这些是在节目播出当天的白天在NBC播出的。
But it's nice for people just to be able to have this kind of collection and be able to just access it. That was kind of my dream was to have like a whole office portal that people could just access this stuff. And not have to go to Best Buy and buy a DVD player like I did. Which by the way, I have played my DVDs so much in the last five years. Jenna, I haven't even shared this with you. My DVD player is malfunctioning. It's starting to make a like a Vee-vee-vee-vee-vee-vee-vee-vee-vee-vee-vee-vee-vee
但能让人们拥有这种合集并能够直接访问，这真的很不错。这可以说是我的梦想，拥有一个整个办公室的门户网站，人们可以访问这些东西。并且不用像我一样去百思买买一台DVD播放器。顺便说一下，我在过去五年里把我的DVD放了无数次。詹娜，我甚至都没有跟你分享过这个。我的DVD播放器出故障了。它开始发出像 Vee-vee-vee-vee-vee-vee-vee-vee-vee-vee-vee-vee-vee
noise and then sometimes I have to hit stop and eject and then like kind of reboot it to get it to work. Anyway, sorry, didn't mean to go off on the DVD. I love the DVDs because we spend a lot of time even just doing the artwork and the, you know, the menus and things like that. Yeah. And we did, we, you know, again, our show, spent a lot of time even just doing the artwork and the menus and things like that. And we did, again, our show, we'll get into it, but as you know, the style of our show,
的声音，有时我不得不按下停止和弹出键，然后重新启动它才能工作。总之，抱歉，我不是故意要扯到DVD上的。我喜欢DVD，因为我们甚至花了很多时间来制作封面、菜单之类的事情。是的。我们确实，我们，你知道的，再次强调，我们的节目，甚至花了很多时间来制作封面、菜单之类的事情。我们的节目，我们会深入探讨，但如你所知，我们节目的风格，
because we were handheld in a 360 environment, we didn't have so much downtime with lighting and things like that. It was like, hey, we're pretty much lit, small adjustments. So we could, and because of the handheld nature of the show, we could shoot faster. So then they would write longer scripts. So we did have a lot of things that were left on the cutting room floor. I mean, just, you know, just a lot of stuff. And some of it was, was a level material.
因为我们在360度环绕环境中手持拍摄，我们在灯光等方面没有那么多停机时间。就像，嘿，我们基本上已经布好光了，只需进行小调整。所以我们可以，而且由于节目的手持特性，我们可以拍摄得更快。所以他们就会写更长的剧本。因此，我们确实有很多东西被留在了剪辑室的地板上。我是说，就是，有大量的素材。有些是，是高质量的素材。
But because the, the episodes on TV were, you know, the time was 21 minutes and 35 seconds to fit a half hour slot, including the main title. So much stuff got cut out. Yeah, I mean, it sounds like at first, you were just like, hey, let's just make a compilation of like bonus material that people can find on Peacock. So they don't have to go to the DVDs and it will be this amazing office portal.
但因为电视上的剧集，你知道的，时长是21分35秒，为了适应包括主片头在内的半小时档期。太多的东西被剪掉了。是的，我是说，听起来一开始，你只是在想，嘿，让我们制作一个人们可以在Peacock上找到的额外素材的合集。这样他们就不用去看DVD了，它将成为这个神奇的办公室门户网站。
Right. We did that and we gave them all of this great extra material, behind the scenes stuff, loopers, all of that. And then Greg said, hey, we have all of this material, all of these deleted scenes. Is there a way we can, you know, re-edit the shows and make- So this is Greg Daniel's idea. This is Greg Daniel's idea. Okay. And he said, you know, and make kind of a, he's like, I don't want to call it like a
没错。我们做到了这一点，我们为他们提供了所有这些精彩的额外素材、幕后花絮、笑场片段，所有这些。然后格雷格说，嘿，我们有所有这些素材，所有这些被删减的场景。有没有办法，你知道，重新剪辑这些节目并制作——所以这是格雷格·丹尼尔斯的主意。这是格雷格·丹尼尔斯的主意。好的。他说，你知道的，做一种，他不想称之为
quintessential, you know, cut because it's the broadcast episodes we originally put on the air were pretty good. Yeah, yeah. But still he said like, you know, maybe we could do something and really this is for the fans. And that's kind of how the super fan title came about, you know, super fan episodes. And he also, this is very sweet. Part of it was with the
精髓版的，你知道的剪辑，因为我们最初在电视上播出的版本已经相当不错了。是的，是的。但他说，你知道的，也许我们可以做点什么，这真的是为了粉丝。这就是“超级粉丝”这个称号的由来，你知道的，超级粉丝集。而且他也是，这非常贴心。部分原因是由于
pandemic going on, there was not a lot of work. This was like, you know, he's like, oh, this will keep Dave busy. So that was, you know, part of the thing because we had worked, you know, right before that I had done Upload season one, and we went right into Space Force, you know, so I was working on these two shows. It was great, you know. We had great casts on Upload. Space Force was amazing. We had Steve Carell again. And then that was it. It was winding down in March. We were at home at that point, editing remotely, doing visual effects as the pandemic hit.
疫情爆发，工作不多。这就好比，你知道的，他说，哦，这会让戴夫有事可做。所以，你知道的，这是其中的一部分，因为我们合作过，就在那之前我刚做完《上传》第一季，然后我们直接进入了《太空部队》，你知道的，所以我当时在做这两个节目。这很棒，你知道的。我们在《上传》里有很棒的演员阵容。《太空部队》太棒了。我们再次邀请到了史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。然后就是这样。它在三月份接近尾声。那时我们在家，远程剪辑，随着疫情来袭而制作视觉特效。
So it was a few months later. I think it was June of 2020 when Greg first talked about it and Peacock was like, yep, go ahead, let's go, do whatever you need. And so we got together with, I got Rob Burnett, who was one of my assistant editors on The Office, and he's become an editor unto himself now. I mean, he's great. He did the Mindy Project, AP Bio, Upload, Space Force. And so he works with me on these episodes. And he preps the stuff, but also cuts. And we send stuff back and forth just as editors.
所以是几个月后。我想是2020年6月，格雷格第一次谈到这件事，Peacock的态度是，行，去吧，开始吧，做你需要做的。所以我们聚在一起，我找到了罗伯·伯内特，他是《办公室》里我的助理剪辑师之一，他现在自己也成了一名剪辑师。我是说，他太棒了。他做过《明迪烦事多》、《生物学A班》、《上传》、《太空部队》。所以他在这些剧集上和我一起工作。他做前期准备，但也负责剪辑。我们作为剪辑师来回发送素材。
Like I say, hey, what do you think of this? And he'll say, yeah, this, this, this. And then he'll send stuff to me. And I'm like, yeah, this is good. I would tweak this a little, things like that. But we've got all the old projects. So we're back into the, I don't know, I'm just excited. But is this really just like a,
就像我会说，嘿，你觉得这个怎么样？他会说，是的，这个，这个，这个。然后他会把东西发给我。我会说，是的，这个不错。我会稍微调整一下，诸如此类。但我们保留了所有旧项目。所以我们又回到了，我不知道，我只是很兴奋。但这个真的只像是一个，
it's like a two man operation. Is it mostly just you and Rob? It's me and Rob, and then we have a couple of assistant editors, Dan Ross and Josh Toomey. And then on the post side, like we have Britt Irwin, who was one of our post supervisors on the office, and Eric Coljens involved. So he's kind of nebulous.
这就像是一个两人团队吗？基本上只是你和罗伯吗？是我和罗伯，然后我们有几个助理剪辑师，丹·罗斯和乔什·图米。然后在后期方面，比如我们有布里特·欧文，他是《办公室》的后期主管之一，还有埃里克·科尔根参与其中。所以他有点像个不定因素。
He started with us and then he kind of floats around every now and then. I see like a bill that he paid for or something like that. But it's just us and then Greg checks in and Howard Klein checks in. But they just trust us at this point. It's like to go through the material. And I can tell you more about that process. But it is a skeleton crew putting the stuff together. And then, and we can talk about the finishing though,
他从我们开始时加入，然后每隔一段时间就四处闲逛。我看到他支付账单或者类似的东西。但只有我们，然后格雷格会来看看，霍华德·克莱因也会来看看。但他们在这个时候完全信任我们。就像是去过一遍素材。关于那个过程，我可以告诉你们更多。但这就是一个精简的团队在把这些东西拼凑在一起。然后，我们可以讨论收尾工作。
because we have, you know, we online these shows, so they look, we want them to look seamless from the original ones. And we have sound mixes and VFX, and it's our same sound mix team, John Cook at Blue Wave, it's who did the office. It's, you know, the same guys, Bobby Maxton from The Office, same guys working on the show.
因为我们要在线上发布这些节目，所以它们看起来，我们希望它们和原版无缝衔接。我们有音效混音和视觉特效，我们的混音团队是同一个，也就是《办公室》的蓝波音效工作室的约翰·库克，你知道的，都是老熟人，还有《办公室》的鲍比·马克斯顿，都是原班人马在做这个节目。
So, Dave, this is fascinating to me. And as Jenna and I have started watching the super fan episodes, we're picking them here and there, sort of seeing which ones are the fan favorites. And I watched the original airing. I had it on my TV with my DVD player, and then I had the Superfan on Peacock and I watched them at the same time. I synced up the beginning and then I had a notepad and when one would diverge, right, I would make a note, I'd get the time code, and then I'd go to
所以，戴夫，这对我来说太迷人了。当詹娜和我开始看超级粉丝版时，我们会这里看一点那里看一点，看看哪些是粉丝最喜欢的。我看了原版首播。我在电视上用DVD播放器看，然后在Peacock上看了超级粉丝版，我同时观看。我把开头对齐，然后我拿了一个记事本，当有内容分叉时，我就做个记录，记下时间码，然后我会去
the shooting draft, I'd see what was new, what was a deleted scene, I would go to the shooting draft, I'd see what was new, what was a deleted, I would go to the DVDs, to the deleted scenes and see like, oh, that's not in deleted scenes, but it's in the shooting draft, I guess we shot it, maybe that's new. So anyway, Jenna and I have been trading crazy convoluted messages to one another, kind of sounds like what you and Rob are doing a little bit.
拍摄台本，看看有什么新内容，什么是删减片段，我会去看看DVD里的删减片段，心想，哦，这不在删减片段里，但它在拍摄台本里，我想我们拍过，也许这是新内容。总之，詹娜和我一直在互相发送疯狂且错综复杂的信息，听起来有点像你和罗布在做的事情。
And I'm so curious to know what your process is about how do you pick what goes in like you must have all this extra footage that isn't in the deleted scenes yeah the first thing I do is watch the show I take the episode I watched the broadcast version right and then I watched the deleted scenes and I watch and again even that we had we had deleted scenes that were on the deleted scenes and I watch, and again, even that, we had deleted scenes that were on the DVDs and even we had deleted scenes that were on NBC. So even just searching.
我很好奇你们的流程是什么，你们是怎么挑选放进去的内容的？你们一定有所有不在删减片段里的额外素材。是的，我做的第一件事就是看节目，我拿着剧集，看播出版，对吧，然后我看删减片段，再看一遍，甚至有些删减片段是DVD里有的，有些是NBC网站上的。所以仅仅是搜索就需要...
Yeah, that's right. Yeah, yeah. And most of the time they overlapped, but NBC always had, the website always had less than the DVD, that's where we would put more stuff. So I'll watch the DVDs. But then I'll go into the assembly and I'll watch the first cut of the assembly and the director's cut
对，没错。对，对。大部分时候它们是重合的，但NBC网站上的内容总是比DVD少，这就是我们会添加更多内容的地方。所以我看DVD。但随后我会进入粗剪版本，观看第一版粗剪和导演剪辑版。
And what I'll do is I have a dupe detector so I can throw the assembly in in the timeline Let me know if I'm getting too technical, but no, but I want this I want the dupe detector. That's amazing So I throw the cut in and we have the you know, we have the online master Which is the you know the picture and then I have all of the tracks underneath, all the original dailies and the audio tracks that we did. The audio is like temp. This isn't the mix track. We have that also.
我会做的是，我有一个重复镜头检测器，所以我可以把粗剪版本放进时间线里。如果我讲得太专业了，请告诉我。不，不，我想要这个，我想要重复镜头检测器。这太棒了。所以我把剪辑版本放进去，我们有在线母带，也就是画面，然后在下方我所有的音轨、所有的原始日常素材和我们制作的音效轨道都在。音频就像是暂时的。这不是混音轨道。我们也有那个。
Right. And the dailies, there's so much. There's so many but we had them all backed up. So I mean that's the thing. We're back in our old projects. I was cursing, I was like, damn it, Dean Holland didn't label this episode like the scenes. You can see mine are all clean and we started having some uniformity early on. I was like, look, we
对。还有日常素材，有太多了。有那么多，但我们把它们都备份了。这就是重点。我们回到了以前的项目中。我当时在咒骂，我想，该死的，迪恩·霍兰德没有像场景那样给这一集贴标签。你可以看到我的都很整洁，我们很早就开始有了一些统一性。我想，看，我们
got to, because if we're jumping into each other's projects, I got to be able to see what scene is this and you got to know what scene. Right, right. We would laugh. We have to have the same system system so you have the dupe so I'll lay in the cut the master and then I'll lay in the assembly and I can see what shots are the same the dupe detector will show me what shots are the same and then what's new so I can go to areas and see oh look here's a couplet as we call it it's like a joke back and
必须这样做，因为如果我们要跳进彼此的项目中，我必须能看清这是哪个场景，你必须知道是哪个场景。对，对。我们会笑。我们必须拥有相同的系统，这样你就有重复镜头检测器，我会把剪辑母带放进去，然后把粗剪放进去，我可以看到哪些镜头是相同的，重复镜头检测器会告诉我哪些镜头是相同的，哪些是新的，这样我就可以去到那些区域，看到，哦，看，这里有一个对白组合，正如我们所说，就像是一个一问一答的笑话
forth that was cut out and I'll watch it and I'll say, oh, this is actually pretty good. So I'll weave it back into the show. Well, that's what's interesting to me. Because sometimes when I'm watching the super fan episodes, I'll notice, well, this scene is all new. Or this talking head is all new. But then I'll be watching a scene like how we watched Hot Girl. And there's the scene where Michael is in the conference
被剪掉了，我看了之后会说，哦，这其实挺不错的。所以我把它重新织回节目中。嗯，这就是我觉得有趣的地方。因为有时当我观看超级粉丝版时，我会注意到，哦，这个场景全是新的。或者这个访谈镜头全是新的。但接着我会看到一个场景，比如我们看《辣妹》的那场，有这样一个场景：迈克尔在会议室里
room with Katie, and he's just watching her unpack. And I notice, wait, this scene is in the original, but I think this has like four seconds of extra creeper stare from Michael. And so, yeah, like this would just be like an example of a couplet that gets added back, not a whole scene. Yeah, and that's the thing, because there's a lot of stuff that never could make it
和凯蒂在一起，他只是看着她拆行李。我注意到，等等，这个场景在原版里有，但我觉得这里多了四秒钟迈克尔那种令人毛骨悚然的凝视。所以，是的，这就好比是一个被加回来的对白组合，而不是一整个场景。是的，就是这样，因为有很多内容永远无法进入
into the deleted scenes, because it's like a joke. Yes, it's like a one-off little thing. Just a comment or something. I noticed one that I thought was so interesting, and I wondered how you did it, Dave, but now that I know about the dupe detector. So Michael has a talking head about how charming he is, but then he's yelling at Ryan, what'd you do to my desktop? Where's my
删减片段，因为它就像一个笑话。是的，就像一个一次性的小包袱。只是一个评论什么的。我注意到一个我觉得非常有趣的地方，我很好奇你是怎么做到的，戴夫，但现在我知道了重复镜头检测器。迈克尔有一个访谈，讲述他有多迷人，但接着他在对瑞安大喊，你对我的桌面做了什么？我的
maps? Where are my maps? But then he goes back to the talking head, but it's overlaid over each other and I was like, how did they do that? But this is how. Well, this is, but some of that, I mean, the dupe detector just helps us to say hey is there stuff that was You know from the assembly that was cut out. That's the first thing that we do but stuff like that then it's editing again It's like oh we have other footage that stuff may have been in the assembly like him yelling at Ryan It may not be that just might be in dailies I mean, it's a so we'll go through look through but we'll through the assembly, and then I'll see also if scenes, I mean, that's the thing even,
地图呢？我的地图在哪里？但接着他又回到了访谈，而且它们是叠印在一起的，我当时想，他们是怎么做到的？但这就是方法。嗯，这就是，但其中一些，我是说，重复镜头检测器只是帮我们确定，嘿，是不是有那些你知道的来自粗剪但被剪掉的东西？那是我们做的第一件事，但像那样的事情，然后又是剪辑了，就像，哦，我们有其他素材，这些东西可能在粗剪里，比如他对瑞安大喊。可能不是，那可能只在日常素材里。我是说，这是一个，所以我们会翻看，仔细查看粗剪，然后我也会看看场景是否，我是说，就是这样，甚至，
I like to say if there's a scene that's in the assembly, a lot of times a scene that was deleted is the same as the deleted scene on the DVDs, but that means it wasn't really polished, like it was taken out in the assembly stage. Like we lost it when we were doing the director's cut. So we've thrown it on the DVD and maybe we've polished it a little bit for the, you know,
我喜欢说，如果有一个场景在粗剪中，很多时候被删除的场景和DVD上的删减片段是一样的，但这意味着它并没有真正打磨好，比如它是在粗剪阶段被拿掉的。就像我们在做导演剪辑版时把它去掉了。所以我们把它放到了DVD上，也许我们为了DVD稍微打磨了一下，你知道的，
to go with the DVDs. But now I have the freedom to kind of go in and clean stuff up. We'll add music if we need to, like where we didn't have the budget for it on the DVDs. I mean, sometimes I've watched some of the deleted scenes and like I can hear the director, you know, things like that. Like so things can get cleaned up, you know, which is nice. I have a couple of rules. Oh, let's hear them.
去配合DVD。但现在我有自由去进入并清理一些东西。如果需要的话，我们会添加音乐，比如我们在DVD上没有预算的地方。我的意思是，有时我看过一些删减片段，我能听到导演的声音，诸如此类的事情。所以有些东西可以被清理干净，你知道的，这很好。我有一对规则。哦，让我们听听。
So I never change a take of the show. Like, I feel that this is the documentary crew have come in and they've gotten more time to make these episodes longer. So they're just adding in more stuff that they've shot. So I'll never change a performance, or very, very rarely. There might be something where I'm like, oh, I need, you know, I'll change a camera angle occasionally, but I'll never, you won't see a different take. If Michael says something this
所以我绝不会改变节目的一个镜头。我觉得这是纪录片摄制组进来了，他们有更多的时间让这些集数变得更长。所以他们只是加入了更多他们拍摄的东西。所以我绝不会改变表演，或者极少极少改变。可能会有这样的情况，比如，哦，我需要，你知道的，我偶尔会改变一个机位角度，但绝不会，你不会看到一个不同的表演。如果迈克尔用这种方式说了某句话
way, I'm not going to, you know, go to a different take of him saying the same line. I will only add, you know, and that's for all of you. I don't want any kind of parallel universes or anything out there. Yes. I appreciate that. That's like the integrity of the show. So as you're making these super fan episodes, you are doing it as if you are the documentary filmmaker. Yeah. And what has already aired is like, yeah, is sacred.
方式，我不会，你知道的，换成他说同一句台词的另一个镜头。我只会添加，你知道的，这适用于所有人。我不希望有任何平行宇宙或类似的东西存在。是的。我很感激。这就像是节目的完整性。所以当你在制作这些超级粉丝版时，你就像是纪录片制片人一样在做。是的。而已经播出的内容就像是，是的，是神圣不可侵犯的。
Yes. I mean, every once in a while, like a reaction shot might come out because we've added more dialogue or something like that, and that was used to cover a gap, let's say. But generally, like, no performance changes. The other thing is that there's no alternate things, like, for example, season three, The Job finale.
是的。我的意思是，偶尔，比如可能会去掉一个反应镜头，因为我们添加了更多的对话或类似的东西，而那个镜头原本是用来掩盖间隙的，比方说。但总的来说，没有表演上的改变。另一件事是，没有备选的版本，例如，第三季，《工作》大结局。
We have footage of Karen sitting at a fountain outside the building crying, and she gets a phone call and she accepts the job. So this was like we shot that because we didn't, I guess we weren't sure which way we were going to go. Yeah, you didn't know who's going to get the job. So we shot, that's not going back into a show because it doesn't track with everything we've seen. But I do see there are things like that that pop up and I'm like, no, we can't use that.
我们有凯伦坐在大楼外喷泉旁哭泣的镜头，她接了一个电话并接受了这份工作。所以这就像我们拍了这个，因为我们当时，我想我们还不确定我们要走哪条路。是的，你们不知道谁会得到这份工作。所以我们拍了，那不会再剪回节目里，因为它与我们看到的一切不连贯。但我确实看到有这样的东西冒出来，我想，不，我们不能用那个。
That's a different path. We really do our best not to contradict things and not to have continuity errors, things like that. Right, keep the purity of the story art as it was intended. I remember doing every once in a while those alternate versions of scenes and I think there's an alternate version of Jim and Pam walking out of the elevator at the end of the job
那是另一条路。我们真的尽最大努力不去自相矛盾，不出现连贯性错误之类的问题。对，保持故事艺术原本的纯粹性。我记得偶尔会做那些场景的备选版本，我想吉姆和帕姆在《工作》结尾走出电梯时有一个备选版本
or something or Jim walking out or me walking out. I remember we were trying to figure out that moment. Right, we did that. We did shoot that alternate version of you guys in the elevator. I don't know if you're in it and he comes in. That's what I couldn't remember either. I feel like I sent it to you at the elevator. I don't know if you're in it and he comes in. That's what I couldn't remember either. I feel like I sent it to you at the time.
或者别的什么，或者吉姆走出来，或者我走出来。我记得我们当时在极力琢磨那个时刻。没错，我们确实那样做了。我们确实拍了你们在电梯里的那个备选版本。我不知道你有没有在里面，然后他进来了。这也是我记不清的地方。我觉得我当时发给你了。我不知道你有没有在里面，然后他进来了。这也是我记不清的地方。我觉得我当时发给你了。
I think you did. You were like, do you remember how we did these alternates? Yeah. You were probably doing your super fan episode. Yeah, but that was the best, you know, I mean, what we got with the job, that moment is just great when he comes in, when you're like, yeah, and then he's like,
我想你发了。你当时说，你还记得我们是怎么拍这些备选版本的吗？是的。你可能正在做你的超级粉丝版。是的，但那是最好的，你知道的，我是说，我们在《工作》中得到的那种，当他进来时，那种时刻简直太棒了，当你说，耶，然后他说，
hey, are you free for dinner? And you're like, yeah. Yeah, your look is so, so beautiful. What was I saying? And it's just, there's so many little gems like that. Although I did find the rehearsal for the proposal that we shot on the backlot very far away, but we have on our backlot by the trailers,
嘿，你有空吃晚饭吗？然后你说，有空。是的，你的表情太，太美了。我刚才在说什么来着？有太多这样的小彩珠了。不过我确实找到了我们在背lot非常远的地方拍摄的求婚彩排，我们在拖车后面的背lot有场地，
the post trailer in the back, I guess Paul Feig, it's weight loss. It was Paul Feig who directed weight loss. And it was his idea to do this big rehearsal. Yeah, but we shot like, you know, Jim proposing to Pam. We wanted to see how it would look just being so far away. I remember that now that you say it. It was so trippy.
后面的后期拖车，我想保罗·费格，那是《减肥》。是保罗·费格执导了《减肥》。他的想法是做这个盛大的彩排。是的，但我们拍了，你知道的，吉姆向帕姆求婚。我们想看看它隔得这么远看起来会是什么样。你这么一说我想起来了。太迷幻了。
And I remember now that I was a little bit like, can't you do this with stand-ins? Because when Jim goes down on one knee for Pam, like that's such a big moment for our characters. And I don't wanna like do it here in the parking lot as a screen test or a camera test. I wanna live it the first time. I wanna save it.
而且我记起来当时我有点觉得，你们不能用替身来做这个吗？因为当吉姆单膝下跪向帕姆求婚时，这对我们的角色来说是一个多么重大的时刻。我不想在停车场里把它当成一个试镜或镜头测试来做。我想第一次去经历它。我想把它留到那一刻。
And I want there to be cars whizzing by and I want there to be rain. We got all that. But somehow you guys convinced me and I do remember going out in the parking lot that day. Well, I didn't even know this existed though until I found it. Well, I guess those guys convinced me. Yeah, I never, because Dean and I- I didn't know that. There are things like that that I've never seen before,
我希望有车子呼啸而过，我希望有雨。我们都得到了。但不知怎么的你们说服了我，我确实记得那天去了停车场。不过在我发现之前我甚至不知道这东西的存在。好吧，我想那些家伙说服了我。是的，我从来没——因为迪恩和我——我不知道那件事。有些像这样的事情我以前从未见过，
you know, because I didn't edit all the episodes. So when I'm working on an episode that I didn't originally cut, there are things that I find where I'm like, oh my gosh, like this is amazing. I can't imagine how much amazing sort of like reliving a chapter of our lives that you get to do because I know just for us when I find a deleted scene or a blooper I haven't seen, it just warms my heart and just immediately makes me happy just remembering that time. Is that part of this job for you Dave? Is you open up all these old folders of our lives? Like do you have moments of nostalgia? Oh always. Yeah. But I've just been so involved with the show
你知道的，因为我没有剪辑所有的单集。所以当我处理一集我最初没有剪辑过的剧集时，我会发现一些东西，让我觉得，哦天哪，这太棒了。我无法想象你能做多少像重温我们生活中的一个章节这样不可思议的事情，因为我知道对我们来说，当我找到一个我没看过的被删减的场景或NG镜头时，它只会温暖我的心，并立即让我感到高兴，只需记住那段时光。对你来说，戴夫，这也是这份工作的一部分吗？就像你打开我们生活中的所有这些旧文件夹一样？就像你有怀旧的时刻吗？哦，总是这样。是的。但我太专注于这部剧了
for so long it's not like it really went away. And especially since people are always, I guess my algorithm, my social media, everything. The office. Yeah. But even just my nephews, they reached a certain age, then they became huge fans. I'm constantly just meeting people who are,
很长一段时间，感觉它并没有真正离开。尤其是因为人们总是，我想我的算法，我的社交媒体，一切。《办公室》。是的。但甚至只是我的侄们，他们到了某个年龄，然后他们成了超级粉丝。我经常遇到这样的人，他们
they just love the show and they're discovering it. And it's easy to see why it's really funny and enjoyable. And just there's so many things that happen throughout the course of the series. Yeah. You know, so I mean, like, I could pontificate about that for, you know, hours, but it's, you know, I'll sit there and stop and watch and laugh. And, you know, I still enjoy it, you know. I mean, that says a lot because you've had to watch so much of The Office, but you still enjoy it, I think is pretty great. Yeah. Are there any things that you found that are like your favorite finds?
他们就是喜欢这部剧，而且他们正在发现它。很容易理解为什么它真的很有趣和令人愉快。而且在整个系列剧的进程中发生了太多的事情。是的。你知道，我的意思是，我可以就此夸夸其谈几个小时，但你知道，我会坐在那里停下来观看并大笑。而且，你知道，我依然很享受它，你知道。我的意思是，这说明了很多问题，因为你不得不观看那么多的《办公室》，但你依然很享受它，我认为这挺棒的。是的。有没有什么你发现的东西是像你最喜欢的发现的？
All right. So the thing that's really amazing is the, and you guys are partially responsible for this. So I'm editing season, I think it was season six. OK, do you hear the papers rustling? Everyone listening is because Dave has this document of all the episodes. And it is it is like a worn document with like writing and checkmarks.
好吧。所以真正令人惊奇的是，你们对此负有部分责任。所以我在剪辑第六季，我想是第六季。好吧，你听到纸张沙沙作响的声音了吗？每个在听的人都能听到，因为戴夫有一份所有剧集的文档。它就像是一份破旧的文档，上面有字迹和勾选标记。
Like it's got a lot of love on it. What is this, Dave? Is this your list? It's just my episode title list. Like this. this was it. And I had this on the show. We made this on the show. Because a lot of times all I need to do is just see the episode name
就像它上面有很多爱意。这是什么，戴夫？这是你的清单吗？这只是我的剧集标题清单。就像这样。这就是它。我在节目里带着这个。我们在节目里做了这个。因为很多时候我需要做的只是看到剧集名称
and then it'll jog whatever information I need. I'm gonna take a picture of you with it because this is a loved one document. It is. It definitely is. You printed that when the show was on the air? Yeah. Oh my gosh. Yeah. And it's got food stains on it. And I could when the show was on the air? Yeah. Oh my gosh.
然后它会唤醒我需要的任何信息。我要给你和它拍张照片，因为这是一个饱含爱意的文档。确实是。绝对是。你在节目还在播的时候打印的吗？是的。哦天哪。是的。而且上面有食物渍。而且我可以在节目还在播的时候打印的吗？是的。哦天哪。
Yeah, and it's got food stains on it. And I could print a new one. But why? You can see like even the hole punches are on the other side and stuff like that. Like whatever, you know. But I don't know, I just like it. I'm, you know, and it's got marks all over it.
是的，而且上面有食物渍。我本可以打印一张新的。但为什么呢？你可以看到甚至打孔都在另一边之类的地方。管他呢，你知道。但我不懂，我就是喜欢它。我，你知道，而且它上面到处都是标记。
It's got notes. I love it. And things like that. I love it. So job fair, season four, we had a ton of deleted scenes and new material that were not used, season four, we had a ton of deleted scenes and new material that were not used, you know, that were just cut out from this episode.
它有笔记。我喜欢它。诸如此类的事情。我喜欢它。所以，招聘会，第四季，我们有大量的被删减场景和没有被使用的新素材，第四季，我们有大量的被删减场景和没有被使用的新素材，你知道的，它们只是被从这一集中剪掉了。
And one of the things was a cold open. And I'm looking at, and it's a complete cold open. And it's Michael Scott with his toilet buddy. Yes, yes. So it's his invention. Yes, toilet buddy. Yes, yes. So it's his invention? Yes, toilet buddy, toilet guard, where he comes out of the bathroom and he's angry and Dwight goes to help him and it turns out
其中一件事是一个冷开场。我在看，这是一个完整的冷开场。那是迈克尔·斯科特和他的马桶伙伴。是的，是的。所以这是他的发明。是的，马桶伙伴。是的，是的。所以这是他的发明？是的，马桶伙伴，马桶护栏，他从浴室出来，他很生气，德怀特去帮他，结果证明
all of his stuff fell into the toilet and then a couple things he threw in anger. That's my favorite part. So I'm like, oh, okay. I mean, I remember this cold open, but I'm looking, did we put it on another episode? It's like, no. I'm like, okay, it's not on the DVDs, Deleted Scenes, so we must have saved it. But what happened was is that by the time we started season five, everything had changed.
他的所有东西都掉进了马桶里，然后有几东西是他气愤之下扔进去的。这是我最喜欢的部分。所以我当时想，哦，好吧。我的意思是，我记得这个冷开场，但我在看，我们把它放到另一集里了吗？好像没有。我心想，好吧，它不在DVD的被删减场景里，所以我们一定把它保存下来了。但情况是，当我们开始第五季的时候，一切都变了。
I'm turning the pages again. Yeah, because Toby was gone and Holly came in. So it was like a whole new thing going on. So it just was lost. Yeah, you couldn't plug it in an episode now because there would be the wrong people in the background. Right, right. So that was the thing.
我又在翻页了。是的，因为托比走了，霍莉来了。所以这就像是一个全新的局面。所以它就这样被遗漏了。是的，你现在无法把它塞进一集里，因为背景里会有错误的人。对，对。所以就是这样。
So I'm looking like, wait, did we not put this anywhere? So I go to search on Google like for this, an article comes up from you guys. From Office Ladies? ladies yeah and it says office ladies talk about a scene that was never aired and it was this and in reading that you had a comment though about something where it was oh I love this thing where he throws his keys in anger or something like that would literally that was the there was an extra thing and that wasn't in the assembly version and I put that in.
所以我心想，等等，我们没有把这个放到任何地方吗？所以我去谷歌上搜索这个，出现了一篇来自你们的文章。来自办公室女士？女士们，是的，它说办公室女士谈论了一个从未播出的场景，就是这个，在阅读时，你对某件事有一个评论，哦，我喜欢他愤怒地扔钥匙之类的事情，简直就是那个，有一个额外的部分，而且那不在粗剪版本中，我把它放进去了。
Oh! That was my favorite part! I mean when I went through to do a polish and it turns out we had so much stuff. We found that in the script. Yes and we reached out to Gene and Lee about it. Again I was looking to see you know is this anywhere I'm checking all these episodes towards the end of season four and then I'm looking at the beginning of season five and then I was like this is weird and? I'm checking all these episodes towards the end of season four, and then I'm looking at the beginning of season five, and then I was like, this is weird. And then I Googled, and then your thing came up. That it said that, you know, there was some news story about you guys talking about this scene. And I think I reached out to you guys and said, hey,
哦！那是我的最爱！我的意思是，当我通读一遍进行润色时，结果我们有这么多的东西。我们在剧本里发现了那个。是的，我们为此联系了吉恩和李。我再次查看，你知道，这在任何地方吗，我正在检查第四季末的所有这些剧集，然后我正在查看第五季初，然后我想这很奇怪，然后我谷歌了一下，然后你们的东西就出来了。上面说，你知道，有一些关于你们谈论这个场景的新闻报道。我想我联系了你们并说，嘿，
we have it. I found it, you know, and it was never a deleted scene or anything. So that's great when you have a full, a fully fledged scene like that. That's just so funny. And again, I get to tweak stuff. So I love the shot with the tennis racket and Pam's face is behind it, like the way that's framed. And there was just other things where, there were other versions even of the scene. And it was like really carving, what's the best version?
我们有它。我找到了，你知道，它从来都不是一个被删减的场景什么的。所以当你有一个完整的那样的场景时，这真是太棒了。这太搞笑了。再说一次，我得调整一些东西。所以我喜欢网球拍的那个镜头，帕姆的脸在它后面，就像那个构图一样。还有其他一些事情，甚至有该场景的其他版本。这就像是在精雕细琢，什么是最好的版本？
Michael's asking everyone who wants to try? You want to try Kevin? And then, coming back to like Creed or Hymn Say, that'll make a great tennis racket. And then there was Kevin and then, you know, coming back to like Creed of him saying, that'll make a great tennis racket. And then there was an extra piece I think that's in the show in the tag. It's like later Toby goes to his desk and he pulls out his tennis racket and he swings it and it's all bent and broken. That's what Michael did. He used Toby's tennis racket. He just taped it up. And Toby goes like that and he's like, hey, you know, he reacts to his broken tennis racket. Oh, amazing. He just taped it up. And Toby goes like this, and he's like, hey, you know, he reacts to his broken tennis racket. So that was a great find.
迈克尔问谁想尝试？你想试试凯文吗？然后，回到像克里德或希姆·塞，那会是一个很棒的网球拍。然后还有凯文，然后，你知道，回到像克里德说的那样，那会是一个很棒的网球拍。然后我觉得还有一个额外的情节在正片片尾。就像后来托比走到他的办公桌前，他拿出他的网球拍，他挥舞了一下，它全弯了而且破了。那是迈克尔做的。他用了托比的网球拍。他只是用胶带缠上了。托比就这样做，然后他就像，嘿，你知道，他对他的破网球拍做出反应。哦，太棒了。他只是用胶带缠上了。托比就这样做，然后他就像，嘿，你知道，他对他的破网球拍做出反应。所以那是一个伟大的发现。
That's a pretty good treasure. Yeah. I can't wait now to go watch it. I want to see it in the super fan episode. We found another complete cold open for the Christmas Wishes episode. What is it? Andy leads everybody singing Christmas carols outside. Do you guys remember that? I think we discussed that this was deleted.
那真是个不错的宝藏。是的。我现在等不及要去看了。我想在超级粉丝版里看到它。我们为《圣诞愿望》那一集找到了另一个完整的冷开场。是什么？安迪领着大家在外面唱圣诞颂歌。你们还记得吗？我想我们讨论过这个被删掉了。
Yeah. It was not a deleted scene. No, it was in the shooting draft. It's in the shooting draft. I don't want to say too much but it's pretty funny and he has a couple talking heads and you guys are singing and he's trying to, he's like you guys start doing the echoes like you're singing Rudolph the Red Nose Reindeer like you know, had a very shiny nose like a light bulb. Yeah, yeah. And he's trying to, he's like, you guys start doing the echoes, like you're singing Rudolph, the Red Nose Reindeer, like, you know, had a very shiny nose like a light bulb. And he's like, guys, no, no, no. And he's trying to convince you that it's really a poignant song. And you know, it's, it's very, I think it's a very funny cold open.
是的。这不是一个被删减的场景。不，它在拍摄剧本里。它在拍摄剧本里。我不想说太多，但它挺搞笑的，他有几个采访镜头，你们在唱歌，他试图，他就像你们开始做回声，就像你们在唱《红鼻子驯鹿鲁道夫》，就像，你知道，有一个非常闪亮的鼻子像个灯泡。是的，是的。他试图，他就像你们开始做回声，就像你们在唱《红鼻子驯鹿鲁道夫》，就像，你知道，有一个非常闪亮的鼻子像个灯泡。他就像，伙计们，不，不，不。他试图说服你们这真的是一首感人的歌。你知道，它，它非常，我认为这是一个非常有趣的冷开场。
Yeah, one of the things we've loved is having the shooting drafts because we read them and I'm like, okay, the scene isn't deleted scenes. We both remember shooting it. It lives somewhere, it's out there somewhere, but it's with you, Dave. Yeah. ["The Last Supper"] Was there ever a storyline in one of the episodes you edited that you didn't get to include? And so now that you're going back, do you remember those and you're like, I want one
是的，我们喜欢的事情之一就是拥有拍摄剧本，因为我们读了它们，然后我就想，好吧，这个场景不在被删减的场景里。我们俩都记得拍过它。它住在某个地方，它在某个地方，但它在你这里，戴夫。["最后的晚餐"] 在你剪辑的一集中，有没有哪个故事线你没能包含进去？所以现在你回过头来，你还记得那些，然后你想，我想要一个
of those in? I mean, I don't know if there's an entire storyline. It's more just scenes. Like a runner. Yeah, I guess that's a better word for it. Because I know sometimes I'll look in the shooting draft and there'll be like a runner with Ryan. There was a runner where he did like a treasure hunt
那些加进去？我的意思是，我不知道是不是有一整条故事线。更多的是场景。就像一个支线。是的，我想那是更好的说法。因为我知道有时我会查看拍摄剧本，会有一个关于瑞恩的支线。有一个支线是他在绩效评估中做了一个寻宝游戏
in performance review. But it's not. It's all in the super fan. That's right. Yeah. And at the end even you discover that it. It was Ryan. It was Ryan himself who gave himself the other thing to do.
在绩效评估里。但它没有。全都在超级粉丝版里。没错。是的。而且最后你甚至发现，是瑞恩。是瑞恩自己给自己安排了另一件要做的事。
Yeah. There's a bunch of runners. I couldn't tell you specifically which ones. But even Meredith, in weight loss is another great example, just because we had stuff going on every week. You know, Meredith gets sunburned. Yes. And she's got the blisters on her face.
是的。有很多支线。我无法具体告诉你哪些。但甚至梅雷迪思，在减肥中是另一个很好的例子，只是因为我们每周都有事情在发生。你知道的，梅雷迪思晒伤了。是的。她的脸上有水泡。
Yes. And in the final episode, you kind of see it, but there's no explanation. Yeah. And people wrote in. They're like, what is up with Meredith's face? Yeah. So that stuff gets restored. Those moments that are really kind of funny that we just didn't have time for it. Well, and something that's really nice about that example is that, you know, because the Meredith storyline of her getting sunburned had to be cut out for time, that also meant, like, you couldn't even go to her for reactions because she would have had this sunburn on her face that made no sense.
是的。在最后一集中，你有点能看到它，但没有解释。是的。人们写信来。他们就像，梅雷迪思的脸怎么了？是的。所以那些东西得到了恢复。那些我们实在没时间播出的、非常搞笑的时刻。嗯，关于那个例子，真正好的一点是，你知道的，因为梅雷迪思晒伤的故事线不得不因为时间原因被剪掉，这也意味着，就像，你甚至不能去找她要反应，因为她的脸会被晒伤，这就说不通了。
So then she kind of ends up not existing in those episodes as much as she would have if she didn't have this sunburn on her face that made no sense. So then she kind of ends up not existing in those episodes as much as she would have if she didn't have this sunburn. So now it's like this whole character gets to come back. Yeah, I mean, they happen. It's not too often, but sometimes there is something that it's such a key thing that you're like, we can't even explain this. We don't have the time,
所以她最终在那些集数里出现的次数，比她没有被晒伤时要少。所以她最终在那些集数里出现的次数，比她没有被晒伤时要少。所以现在就像这个角色获得了回归。是的，我的意思是，它们发生了。虽然不多，但有时确实会有一些如此关键的事情，让你觉得，我们甚至无法解释这一点，我们没有时间，
so we just have to kind of cut around it. Yeah, yeah. There's some stuff, like the time, so we just have to kind of cut around it. Yeah. There's some stuff, like I said, where we've added, like even parkour. We've added a bunch of shots into the parkour. We did a bunch of things like they're outside, they're spinning this giant wheel, and one of them jumps on it and then hurts their crotch and things like that. There's just lots of little things that pepper in.
所以我们只能绕过它。是的，有些事情，就像我说的，我们添加了，甚至像跑酷。我们在跑酷里添加了很多镜头。我们做了一些事情，比如他们在外面，他们在转动这个巨大的轮子，其中一个人跳上去然后伤到了胯部之类的。有很多小东西点缀在其中。
Another great example is business school. Michael is, you know, he's talking to the students at the school. And I didn't, again, I didn't edit the episode originally, but there's two takes of Michael where he's ad-libbing. And not a lot of this made it in because the written stuff was great. But like he's got two takes. Steve Carell is ad-libbing with the students. Oh, fun. And it was just, you know, and so that stuff made it into the show. I'll give you another example of something.
另一个很好的例子是商学院。迈克尔在，你知道的，他在和学校的学生交谈。我没有，再说一次，我最初没有剪辑那一集，但迈克尔有两段即兴发挥的镜头。很大一部分没有被放进去，因为写好的内容很棒。但他有两个镜头。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔在和学生们即兴发挥。哦，很有趣。这只是，你知道的，所以那些东西被放进了剧集里。我给你举另一个关于某事的例子。
In Michael's last Dundee's, everybody's coming in and they're, again, I didn't edit this episode. I didn't see this footage. Everybody's coming in at the beginning and Dwight is kind of judging everyone. He's like, strangely appropriate, like adequate. Oh, everyone's outfits. I remember. Everyone's outfits. So I'm watching and then there's a take and Ryan comes in. He's like
在迈克尔的最后一届邓迪奖上，每个人都走进来，而且，再说一次，我没有剪辑这一集。我没有看过这段素材。每个人在开头都进来了，德怀特有点在评判每个人。他表现得有点奇怪地合适，就像很称职。哦，每个人的穿着。我记得。每个人的穿着。所以我正看着，然后有一个镜头，瑞恩进来了。他说的是
the last one. But there's a take where someone comes in after Ryan and it's Stephen Merchant. What? Stephen Merchant walks in and Dwight's like, Oh God. And I'm like, this is great. And he starts laughing and I'm like, this is great. We're putting this in the show. Like this can live in the show. So I guess Stephen was probably just like hanging out. He was visiting. I remember that he was there that week. Oh my gosh. And they just threw him in that, that line up. So he came in and nobody was expecting, like Rain was not expecting it. It just was this thing.
最后一个。但有一个镜头是有人在瑞恩之后进来，那是斯蒂芬·莫昌特。什么？斯蒂芬·莫昌特走了进来，德怀特就好像，哦天哪。然后我就想，这太棒了。他开始大笑，然后我就想，这太棒了。我们要把它放进剧里。这可以在剧里保留。所以我想斯蒂芬当时可能只是在闲逛。他在探班。我记得他那周在那儿。哦天哪。他们就把他扔进了那个阵容里。所以他进来了，没有人预料到，雷恩也没有预料到。事情就是这样。
And you could see them laughing, but like we clip it right before it becomes a blooper. So it's just like, just one other person comes in and it's like, this is like a real super fan thing. Cause if they recognize him, they're like, Oh, look at that's Steven, you know, co-creator of the original office, you know, coming in. Well, and of course we have Ricky Gervais
你能看到他们在笑，但我们在它变成NG镜头之前就把它剪掉了。所以就像，只是另一个人走了进来，这就好像是一个真正的超级粉丝梗。因为如果他们认出他，他们会觉得，哦，看，那是斯蒂芬，你知道的，原版《办公室》的联合创作者，你知道，走进来。嗯，当然我们有瑞奇·热维斯
in a cameo on the show. And now I love that in the super fan episode, Stephen is represented too. That's cool. So whenever I find stuff like that, I get very excited. And I'm like, oh my god. And I was messaging Claire, because Claire Scanlon cut the episode originally.
在剧中客串。现在我很高兴在超级粉丝版里，斯蒂芬也被展现出来了。这很酷。所以每当我发现类似的东西时，我都会非常兴奋。然后我就想，哦天哪。我当时在给克莱尔发信息，因为克莱尔·斯坎伦最初剪辑了这一集。
I'm like, Claire, there's a shot of Stephen Merchant. And maybe, like, I don't even know if it was in the bloopers. Do you know what I mean? Like, I didn't even, I had no recollection of it. And so that's why I was like, so I was just very excited. I was like, oh, this is great. We're going to work this into the show. And, you know, so.
我就说，克莱尔，有一个斯蒂芬·莫昌特的镜头。也许，就像，我甚至不知道它是不是在NG花絮里。你知道我的意思吗？就像，我甚至不记得了，我完全没有印象。这就是为什么我当时想，所以我非常兴奋。我就想，哦，这太棒了。我们要把这个弄进剧里。你知道的，所以。
But what happens when you get to an episode and I'm thinking of like moving on? There's no deleted scenes for that. That to an episode, and I'm thinking of like moving on. Mm-hmm. There's no deleted scenes for that. That was an episode, that was Jon Favreau's episode, that was one episode, that got turned into two episodes. We even had to shoot an extra storyline to fill it out. And that had to be added in. So like, is there anything extra for that?
但当你看到某一集时会发生什么，我想到的是比如《重归于好》？那一集没有删减片段。那到了一集，我想的是比如《重归于好》？嗯哼。那一集没有删减片段。那是那一集，那是乔恩·费儒导的那集，原本是一集，被拆成了两集。我们甚至不得不补拍一条额外的故事线来充实它。而那必须加进去。所以，比如说，那一集有什么额外内容吗？
What do you do? I'm not there yet, so we'll see. Have you had any episodes yet where there's just like, I got nothing? So we started, I didn't know how it was going to work if we were going to do for every episode or just certain ones. And then Peacock was like, can you do for all of them? I was like, yeah. So we started doing that. There were a few episodes. Sometimes it was even just, there just wasn't a ton of stuff. We may have shot an episode in four days, you know, like sometimes we would do that. So one of them was the negotiation, which is a favorite of mine. Mike Schur wrote this one.
你怎么办？我还没到那一步，所以我们走着瞧。你有没有遇到过这样的剧集，就是那种——我什么都没有？所以我们开始了，我不知道这会怎么运作，是我们每一集都要做，还是只做特定的几集。然后孔雀（Peacock）就说，你能把所有的都做一遍吗？我就说，行。所以我们开始这样做了。有那么几集。有时甚至只是，根本没有大量的素材。我们可能在四天内就拍完了一集，你知道的，有时候我们会那样做。所以其中一集是《谈判》，这是我最喜欢的一集。迈克尔·舒尔写了这一集。
It's so good. That's the one Michael wears a ladies suit. Ladies suit, yes. And I honestly, I... Mysterious. Mysterious. Which it has shoulder, and it has shoulder pads. And no pockets. And no pockets.
太棒了。那是迈克尔穿女士西装的那集。女士西装，是的。老实说，我…… 神秘。神秘。它有垫肩，而且它有垫肩。没有口袋。没有口袋。
So don't get us started. And that upset, I also, I tell people like, if you want a great writing, just an exercise, it's just watching that and seeing what a great script it is and how the turns come and how like the act one is one thing and act two goes to another place and act three. I mean, it's just so good and such a good use of the ensemble, like just a, like a perfect episode. Yeah. And there were not deleted scenes.
所以别让我们打开话匣子。那一集，我也，我告诉人们，如果你想要很棒的写作，就当是一个练习，只要看那一集，看看这是多么棒的剧本，情节是如何转折的，第一幕是一回事，第二幕去到了另一个地方，还有第三幕。我的意思是，真的是太棒了，对群演的运用也太棒了，就像一个完美的剧集。是的。而且没有删减片段。
There were not deleted scenes for that. I don't think there were any, but I found one thing that was like a Michael talking head. And so that made it in and that made it a super fan episode. Oh my gosh. And it was him talking about shopping and like, it was just enough that it wouldn't ruin the episode in any sense. But it was still just something new. So that made it a superfan episode. We have other episodes that are, you know, we did producers
那一集没有删减片段。我觉得没有，但我发现了一个类似迈克尔单人访谈的东西。所以它被保留了，这让它成为了一集超级粉丝版。哦天哪。那是他谈论购物的内容，就这么一点点，无论如何都不会毁了这一集。但它依然是一些新的东西。所以这让它成为了一集超级粉丝版。我们还有其他剧集，你知道的，我们在DVD上做过
cuts on the DVDs. So I know like maybe starting in season six or seven or eight, we started doing like longer cuts. And it's still like, oh, it's tough then to find it. You know, I still want to give the fans even something more. So it is tricky sometimes just finding, is there anything else? Can we get anything else that's great, that's worth putting in? And even though fans, a lot of them haven't seen these producers' cuts, again, they're on the DVDs. Right.
制作人剪辑版。所以我知道大概从第六季、第七季或第八季开始，我们开始做那种更长的剪辑版。而且依然是，哦，那时候要找到素材就很难了。你知道，我还是想给粉丝们更多一点东西。所以有时候找找看还有没有别的什么，真的很棘手，还能找到其他很棒的、值得放进去的东西吗？尽管很多粉丝都没有看过这些制作人剪辑版，但它们又确实在DVD上。没错。
But, you know, they haven't been on streaming or anything, but still I do, we look hard and we do. Every episode has at least something new that hasn't been seen before. Okay, well this brings me to this question. So, and I know you haven't done season nine yet, but do you have your favorite super fan episodes? If we're gonna go and watch some of these do you
但是，你知道的，它们没有在流媒体上播过或者别的什么，不过我还是，我们努力寻找，而且确实找到了。每一集至少都有一些以前没见过的新内容。好吧，那这就让我想到了这个问题。所以，我知道你还没做第九季，但你有你最喜欢的超级粉丝版剧集吗？如果我们去看其中一些，你
have like your top five that you think are a must watch? You know I love them all. It sounds like Business School maybe. Business School has some great stuff I mean I'm writing that down. Job Fair has a ton of stuff I mean there was a whole storyline and again sometimes it's I have to check my notes to see what's we send a list of the new stuff so it have to check my notes to see what's, we send a list of the new stuff. So it'll say what was deleted scenes and what's new material. We'll send it to Peacock. Like just as we go through and they can even time how much is new material and how much has been seen before in some way. But there's a whole, I mean, there's so much stuff with,
有没有列出你觉得必看的五大推荐？你知道我都很喜欢。听起来好像有《商学院》？《商学院》有些很棒的内容，我的意思是，我把这个记下来。《招聘会》有一大堆内容，我的意思是，那里有一整条故事线，而且话说回来，有时候我得查查笔记看看是什么，我们发送了一份新内容的清单，所以我得查查笔记看看是什么，我们发送了一份新内容的清单。所以它会列出哪些是删减片段，哪些是新素材。我们会发给孔雀。就像我们过一遍那样，他们甚至可以计算出有多少是新素材，有多少是以某种方式以前见过的。但这里有一大堆，我的意思是，有太多关于……的内容，
like job fair has like 20 minutes of extra footage. I mean, that's really a big one. There's a lot of stuff. Basketball has a lot of stuff. And Boys and Girls has a lot of stuff. There's a lot of stuff with Lonnie. It's great seeing Lonnie and Madge. Madge has this whole thing where she's wanted in like three states and stuff like that, you know. She doesn't want the camera on her. And there's just more stuff like with Michael, like he goes down there and right away he's fiddling with the boom box and he breaks the antenna and then he tries to like stick it back on. I mean there's, I love that episode.
比如《招聘会》有大约20分钟的额外素材。我的意思是，那真的是非常大的一集。有很多内容。《篮球赛》有很多内容。《男孩与女孩》也有很多内容。有很多关于朗尼的内容。看到朗尼和玛奇真的很棒。玛奇有一整段内容，说她在三四个州被通缉之类的，你知道的。她不想让镜头对着她。还有更多关于迈克尔的内容，比如他走到那边，立刻摆弄起手提音箱，然后把天线弄断了，接着他试图把它粘回去。我的意思是，我很喜欢那一集。
There's a lot of extra comedy in there. Yeah, I mean so many of these have great stuff. I could do a little more research and message you, like what really are my top five or what I think are worthwhile. I can do that. We will break down Dave's super fan list. Yeah, Dave's top five.
里面有很多额外的喜剧效果。是的，我的意思是，这里面有太多精彩的内容了。我可以做更多研究然后给你发信息，看看我真正的前五名是什么，或者我觉得哪些是值得看的。我可以做到这一点。我们会梳理戴夫的超级粉丝版清单。是的，戴夫的前五名。
Yeah, I'll do that for you. I'll do that. And if it's more than top five, let us know. But you can start with top five. I'll start with top five. Well, we often debate on the podcast, does a deleted scene count toward the universe of the office or a character?
好的，我会为你做的。我会做的。如果超过前五名，请让我们知道。但你可以从前五名开始。我从前五名开始。嗯，我们经常在播客里争论，删减片段算不算《办公室》宇宙或某个角色的一部分？
And we sort of came to the conclusion that no, that if it's said in a deleted scene, it didn't count. So for example, in the episode Baby Shower, there is this deleted scene about where it implies that Kevin might be the father of Jan's baby. Right. And then also in the shooting draft it says maybe it was Andy Roddick. So she got her sperm from Andy Roddick. So what is the true canon of the show? Is it now the superfan episodes or is it the original
然后我们得出的结论是，不算，如果在删减片段里说过的话，就不算数。例如，在《婴儿淋浴》那一集里，有一个关于暗示凯文可能是简的孩子父亲的删减片段。没错。然后在拍摄剧本里也写着，也许是安迪·罗迪克。所以她的精子是从安迪·罗迪克那里来的。那么这部剧真正的正史（canon）是什么？是现在的超级粉丝版，还是最初的
airing? You know this is a this is a deep question. We talked to Greg about it too. Yeah, this is my take on it. Like I don't look at deleted scenes as canon. Okay. Okay, because they've been, you know, that's not to say that some of them aren't, but as they're just deleted scenes, I don't look at them as canon.
播出版本？你知道这是一个深刻的问题。我们也和格雷格聊过这个。是的，这是我的看法。我并不把删减片段视为正史。好的。好的，因为它们已经被，你知道的，这并不是说其中一些不是，但既然它们只是删减片段，我不把它们看作正史。
Okay. As I've gone through and restored stuff to the show, I do look at them as canon. Okay. As I've gone through and restored stuff to the show, I do look at it as canon, because now I see it as like a fully finished episode. I think fans can go back and forth. I think it's really up to the individual, but I look at them as like, now that these things have been put into a show
好的。当我经历并将内容恢复到剧中时，我确实将它们视为正史。好的。当我经历并将内容恢复到剧中时，我确实将其视为正史，因为现在我把它看作是一个完全完成的剧集。我认为粉丝们可以来回转换。我认为这真的取决于个人，但我把它们看作是，既然这些东西已经被放进了一部
that's a finished product, so to speak, I can look at them as canon. Well, you've put so much thought into it and you've been really, you know, careful to protect the integrity of the show. So I could see that your locked superfan episode for you is now canon. So here's something. This was a deleted scene originally. Okay.
可以说是完成品的剧集里，我就可以把它们视为正史。嗯，你在上面倾注了太多的心血，而且你一直，你知道的，非常小心地保护这部剧的完整性。所以我可以看出，对你来说，定稿的超级粉丝版现在就是正史。所以这里有个情况。这原本是一个删减片段。好的。
So this was, this was an episode I directed. Um, I believe it was mafia scene originally. Okay. So this was an episode I directed. I believe it was Mafia. Okay. This is one of my favorites. We love Mafia. In our re-watch. Did you re-watch the Superfan version? No, not yet.
所以这是，这是我导演的一集。嗯，我记得原本是《黑手党》那一集。好的。所以这是我导演的一集。我记得是《黑手党》。好的。这是我最喜欢的剧集之一。我们很喜欢《黑手党》。在我们的重看中。你重看过超级粉丝版吗？没有，还没有。
Oh, should we put that on our list? We're writing it down. In Mafia, you know what the deleted scenes are in that episode. Very controversial. Erin is cleaning and she destroys... Oh, she destroys Pam's watercolor. Not in the superfan episode. So in the superfan episode, she doesn't clean, but we still have
哦，我们应该把它列入清单吗？我们正在把它记下来。在《黑手党》里，你知道那一集里的删减片段是什么。非常有争议。艾琳在打扫卫生，她毁了…… 哦，她毁了帕姆的水彩画。没有在超级粉丝版里。所以在超级粉丝版里，她没有打扫卫生，但我们依然保留了
her storyline. We've restored enough of her storyline where she's just kind of... She's trying to impress Pam. She's trying to impress. She's trying to impress, everybody's kind of giving her crap and they're like, you'll never be Pam and all this. So I feel like the best elements of that story and even at the, where she calls, we still have her calling and Pam's like, please don't call me again.
她的故事线。我们恢复了她足够多的故事线，让她只是那种……她试图给帕姆留下好印象。她试图留下好印象。她试图留下好印象，每个人都对她评头论足，他们说，你永远也成不了帕姆之类的。所以我觉得那个故事里最好的元素，甚至在她打电话的那场戏里，我们依然保留了她打电话的戏，帕姆说，请不要再给我打电话了。
Cause that was the runner with Pam and Jim is everyone's calling them. But even at the end of the episode where originally you saw the painting was gone on the wall, we digitally put the painting back in the last two shots. No. Now, in a few other episodes after that, it'll be- It's not there. It's not there.
因为那是帕姆和吉姆的一个常设包袱，每个人都在给他们打电话。但甚至在这一集结尾，原本你看到墙上的画不见了，我们在最后两个镜头里用数字技术把画重新加了回去。不会吧。现在，在之后的其他几集里，它会——它不在。它不在。
Whatever. They were cleaning the frame or whatever, the glass or whatever. Did you put it in digitally now? In those later episodes? No. It's gone. It'll be- But I'm saying the end of this episode, there's shots with her and the painting is there. There's never any destruction to the painting. Pam's painting. Yeah. Still.
管他呢。他们在清理画框还是什么的，玻璃还是什么的。你现在把它用数字技术加进去了？在后来的那些集里？没有。它没了。它会——但我的意思是这一集结尾，有她和画在一起的镜头。对画从来没有任何破坏。帕姆的画。是的。依然。
Still. So I will just buy that they, whatever, they had to clean the frames or whatever they, I don't know, they had to re-flatten the paint, I don't know. Whatever was, that's why it's missing for a few episodes and it's back. But it was never destroyed. It's just one of those things, just like Karen getting the job offer, it never happened. There are some things that we cannot bring back or reinsert into the show. It's like the Voldemort. These things are not spoken, they did not happen.
依然。所以我愿意相信他们，随便吧，他们必须清理画框或者他们必须做什么，我不知道，他们必须把画重新弄平，我不知道。不管是什么原因，这就是为什么它在几集里消失了又回来了。但它从来没有被破坏。这只是其中一件事，就像凯伦得到工作机会一样，那从未发生过。有些事情我们无法带回或重新插入剧中。这就像伏地魔。这些事情不能说出口，它们没有发生过。
That's right. But I liked, I appreciated Erin's, you know, it was a shame, but I was like, you know, if we get rid of this beat and we get rid of like the, you know, there's a scene with her and Kelly that we had with Kelly working on the, I was like, you get rid of that, the rest of the stuff is actually very funny and that she's trying so hard. And she even has a moment where she's on the phone with you. She's like, you know, where she's, you know, she's kind of passive aggressive towards you. Like I'll never be as good as you. And it's,
没错。但我喜欢，我很欣赏艾琳的，你知道的，这很遗憾，但我就想，你知道，如果我们去掉这个节拍，去掉像，你知道的，有一场她和凯莉的戏，我们原本拍了凯莉在忙着，我就想，你去掉那个，其余的内容其实非常搞笑，而且她那么努力。她甚至有一场戏在跟你打电话。她说，你知道的，她在那儿，你知道的，她对你有点被动攻击。就像我永远不会像你一样好。而且它，
it's just, I thought all that stuff was really funny and worth keeping, a painting still there at the end. Dave, how lucky are fans to have you making these? I know. Because the thoughtfulness with which, and the care that you put into each one of these episodes, just talking about how much time it must have taken you to be like, okay, I want to preserve this very funny Aaron storyline, but I know I can't ever destroy the painting.
它，我以为所有这些内容都真的很搞笑，值得保留，画最后还在那里。戴夫，粉丝们有你来制作这些节目是多么幸运啊！我懂的。因为你对这些剧集中的每一集都倾注了深思熟虑和关怀，只要想想你一定花了很多时间去思考，好吧，我想要保留这个非常搞笑的艾琳故事线，但我知道我绝对不能毁掉那幅画。
And then, but you figured it out. And I know you have taken that same love and care with every single episode, which, and it's just what you put into your work. It's just such a beautiful thing to see. And we're so lucky. Well, thank you. I mean, I appreciate that. It's just such a beautiful thing to see. And we're so lucky. Well, thank you. I mean, I appreciate that.
然后，但是你解决了它。我知道你对每一集都倾注了同样的爱心和关怀，这，这就是你投入到工作中的东西。看到这一幕真是太美妙了。我们太幸运了。嗯，谢谢。我的意思是，我很感激。看到这一幕真是太美妙了。我们太幸运了。嗯，谢谢。我的意思是，我很感激。
But I just, I don't know, I just love the show. I mean, it's given me so much. Yeah. But I just, I do, I just love and I care about the show so much. That shows through though, Dave. It really does. Even, you know, we're just entering the world of the superfan episodes and just watching them them I can see how
但我只是，我不知道，我就是爱这部剧。我的意思是，它给了我太多。是的。但我只是，我确实，我很爱这部剧，也很在乎它。不过这表现出来了，戴夫。真的表现出来了。甚至，你知道的，我们才刚进入超级粉丝版的世界，光是看着它们，我就能看出
thoughtful and what butter hands for them to be in. I want to watch them all now. I really do. I mean and thank God it's you. Yeah. Really thank God this wasn't just footage that you just turned over to Peacock and then someone who was never part of the show started tinkering with it. Yeah. When I heard that they were gonna do these super fan episodes, I panicked a little bit. I was a little worried because I didn't know if it was gonna be someone who didn't know the world the way you know it. Yeah, and then when I heard it was you
这是多么深思熟虑，交到了一双多么可靠的手里。我现在想把它们全看完。我真的想。我的意思是，感谢上帝是你。是的。真的感谢上帝，这些素材不是你直接交给孔雀，然后一个从来没有参与过这部剧的人开始对它瞎折磨。是的。当我听说他们要做这些超级粉丝版的时候，我有点恐慌。我有点担心，因为我不知道会不会是一个根本不懂这个世界、不如你那样了解它的人。是的，然后当我听说那是你
and it was Rob Burnett and then it was Greg and was overseeing it, I was like, okay, good. And that's the thing, yeah, I didn't want anybody else to, I mean, unless it was Dean or Claire. Sure, sure. I have sent cuts to Claire where I've sent stuff for her to weigh in on like, hey, I didn't want anybody else to, I mean, unless it was Dean or Claire. Sure, sure. I have sent cuts to Claire where I've sent stuff for her to weigh in on like, hey, what do you think of this and stuff. But these are the original editors of the show.
还有罗伯·伯内特，然后是格雷格在监督，我就想，好吧，太好了。就是这样，是的，我不想让任何人去碰，我的意思是，除非是迪恩或克莱尔。当然，当然。我把剪辑版发给克莱尔过，我把素材发给她让她权衡，比如，嘿，我不想让任何人去碰，我的意思是，除非是迪恩或克莱尔。当然，当然。我把剪辑版发给克莱尔过，我把素材发给她让她权衡，比如，嘿，你觉得这个怎么样之类的话。但这些都是这部剧最初的剪辑师。
Yeah, and Dean I trust, you know, with things. But I was like, yeah, I couldn't handle anybody else, you know, like doing that stuff. And that's why I mean, like, it's a small group, it's just us. I mean, you know, Rob is amazing and he knows the show so well too. The other thing that I get to do when I'm looking at all the dailies is that I get to revisit the talking heads. And a lot of times we have, you know, different texts for talking heads. The candy bag alts. There were so many. The candy bag alts and things like that. And sometimes they're different enough that it'd be
是的，对于有些事情，迪恩我是信任的，你知道的。但我就想，是的，我无法接受其他人，你知道的，去做那些事。这就是为什么我的意思是，这是一个小圈子，只有我们。我的意思是，你知道的，罗伯太棒了，他也对这部剧非常了解。当我查看所有每日拍摄素材时，我能做的另一件事就是，我可以重新审视单人访谈。很多时候我们有，你知道的，针对单人访谈的不同台词。糖果袋的替代台词。有太多了。糖果袋的替代台词之类的。有时它们的区别足够大，以至于
great to get this other talking head in. In the original show it was like, you picked one for this moment. But now let's say if I have Pam commenting on something and then Angela comments on something, I can go back to Pam again and put another Pam talking head or a Phyllis talking head. So that's been great that I can add these things back in,
把这个不同的单人访谈放进去会很棒。在原版剧中，就像是，你为这个时刻挑选了一个。但现在假设如果我对帕姆对某事的评论，然后安吉拉对某事的评论，我可以再次回到帕姆那里，放另一个帕姆的单人访谈或者菲尔斯的单人访谈。所以这真的很棒，我可以把这些东西重新加回来，
these talking heads that were, you know, that are awesome and just, you know, there was no place for them. And you wouldn't put them on a DVD necessarily either because it's like, it's tied to a scene or it's just, you know, I call them like orphans, you know? I think I noticed something like that in this Hot Girl super fan episode.
这些原本是，你知道的，很棒的单人访谈，只是，你知道的，没有它们的位置。而且你也不一定非得把它们放在DVD上，因为这就像是，它跟某个场景绑在一起，或者只是，你知道的，我称它们为孤儿，你知道的？我想我在这一集《辣妹》超级粉丝版里注意到了类似的东西。
There are so many talking heads of Michael talking about why he's so attractive to women or why he's handsome or why he's a catch and they're kind of sprinkled throughout the episode and I didn't notice them in the script either I feel like these were some Steve improvs but they're candy bag all yeah there's like three and you even have one that's like as the tag and I was like oh my gosh I bet you must have one that's like as the tag and I was like oh my gosh I bet you must have just unlocked all of these amazing bits of Steve explaining why Michael is such a ladies man. Yeah and and what's really great is
有好多迈克尔的近景独白，都在讲他为什么对女性那么有吸引力，或者为什么他那么帅，或者他为什么是个抢手货，这些内容在这一集里零星散落着，我在剧本里也没注意到，我觉得这些是史蒂夫即兴发挥的，但它们就像糖果包里的杂锦一样——对啊，大概有三个，你甚至还有一个当成了尾声，当时我就想，天哪，我敢说你肯定解锁了所有这些精彩片段，都是史蒂夫在解释为什么迈克尔这么有女人缘。对，而且真正棒的是，
like even with the tags and stuff like that you can we can jump cut now you know what I mean I can for a tag especially you can jump we never would do that in the show but now I feel like it might even be possible in the show I've jump cut some stuff. But in the tag, I can just get you like his best bits. And he goes off on a lot of things. Like basketball, he talks about, he compares basketball to sharks and he's saying how sharks are such, you know, they just want to play. And he goes off on this whole tangent and there's all this B-roll that we plugged in. And actually, Steve Carell actually
就像哪怕是那些尾声之类的片段，我们现在也可以用跳切了，你知道我的意思吗？尤其是对于尾声，你可以做跳切，我们以前在剧中绝不会那样做，但现在我觉得在剧中甚至都有可能了，我跳切了一些内容。但在尾声里，我可以直接把他的最精彩片段剪给你。他会即兴扯很多事情。比如篮球，他会谈到，他把篮球比作鲨鱼，他说鲨鱼是多么的，你知道的，它们只是想玩。然后他就会扯开话题说一大堆，我们还插进去了各种B面素材。实际上，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔还
directed Secretary's Day. And at the end, when he was doing talking heads with the cast, he would have them do impressions of other cast members. Uh-huh. What? Of other characters. Yes.
执导了《秘书节》。最后，当他和演员们一起做近景独白时，他会让演员们模仿其他演员。呃——哈？什么？模仿其他角色。是的。
Yeah. Yeah. So like, Pam does an impression of Jim. Dwight does an impression of Jim. Jim does an impression of Angela. Brian does an impression of Jim, Dwight does an impression of Jim, Jim does an impression of Angela, Brian does an impression of Chandler which I thought was funny and then he's like oh that's Chandler. And are these in the super fan? These are in the super fan. And is this like as a jump cut tag? It's not even I mean it's just one after another they're all just yeah but it's like a
对。对。所以就像，帕姆模仿吉姆。德怀特模仿吉姆。吉姆模仿安吉拉。布莱恩模仿吉姆，德怀特模仿吉姆，吉姆模仿安吉拉，布莱恩模仿钱德勒，我觉得这挺搞笑的，然后他说哦那是钱德勒。这些在爆迷版里吗？这些在爆迷版里。这就像是一个跳切的尾声吗？甚至都不是，我的意思是，它们就是一个接一个，全都是——对，但它就像是一个
montage of people doing impressions. I wanted to ask you about this because I always felt like when we did Talking Heads and we were handed sheets of these candy bag alts, that was where you could really play around. The writers got to play around, the actors got to play around, and it didn't affect the story that much. So when I thought about you assembling
大家在模仿各种角色的蒙太奇。我想问你这个，因为我总觉得，当我们做近景独白时，手里拿着那些糖果包备用片段的纸张，那是你真正可以大展身手的地方。编剧们可以发挥，演员们可以发挥，而且它对剧情没有太大影响。所以当我想到你把
these super fan episodes, I was like, oh, I bet there's a treasure trove of Talking Heads. Even in the deleted scenes, some episodes are just a list of talking heads that didn't make it in. So I love hearing that because that is just so fun to me. I'm going to look for those. Yeah, there's a lot of great talking heads from you guys. Oh, yeah, some existed as deleted scenes, you know, but like, but maybe only maybe only one. So if there would have been one deleted talking head of like, let's say Creed, you probably have 15 that he did that day.
这些爆迷版剧集剪辑到一起时，我就想，天哪，我敢打赌这里面一定有海量的近景独白宝藏。哪怕在删减片段里，有些集也只是一长串没能播出的近景独白。所以我很乐意听到这些，因为这对我来说太有趣了。我要去找找看。对，你们有很多精彩的近景独白。哦，对，有些是以删减片段的形式存在的，你知道的，但也许只有——也许只有一个。所以，如果原本只有一个删减的独白，比如说是克里德的，那你可能手里有他那天拍的15个。
Yeah, like even early on Pam talks about her house and like she talks about her, I think her dream house, but also about Roy and the family. The family really likes Roy. Like, you know. That was based on my document that I wrote about Pam. Yeah. I was like, why is she still with him?
对，就像早期帕姆谈到她的房子，她谈到了她的，我想是她的梦想之家，但也谈到了罗伊和这个家庭。这个家庭真的很喜欢罗伊。就像，你知道的。那是根据我写的关于帕姆的文档来的。对。当时我在想，她为什么还跟他在一起？
Cause there's such a mismatch. And I was like, you know what I think it is? I think it's that her family loves this guy, you know? And when your family likes your boyfriend and the families like each other and she likes his family. It's sort of like you're so enmeshed. And I remember like somebody can co-op this
因为他们太不般配了。然后我在想，你知道我觉得是怎么回事吗？我觉得是因为她的家人很喜欢这家伙，你知道吗？当你的家人喜欢你的男朋友，两家人互相喜欢，而且她也喜欢他的家人。这就有点像是你们纠缠得太深了。我记得好像有人在配合这个
or someone asking me questions and I weaved that into a talking head. The whole thing is, yeah, it's there. Did that make it in somewhere? Yeah, that's in the super fan episode. I think it's season one or season two. Yeah, it must be. But you talk about like the jet skis that he spent the money on, the jet skis, all the stuff
或者有人问我问题，我把这些融合进了一个近景独白里。整件事就是，对，它就在那儿。那个最后被剪进正片里了吗？对，就在爆迷版那一集里。我想那是第一季还是第二季。对，肯定是的。但你谈到他把钱花在水上摩托艇上，水上摩托艇，还有所有这些
that you came up with, that was recorded. And then, so it's in the episode. Oh my gosh, that means so much to me. So it is a treasure trove of things like that. So I did want to say with the talking heads, it's almost its own animal that these can like now live and we can have more than one where it doesn't feel like, you know, we had the time constraints before and we can only pick one.
你想出来的东西，都被录下来了。然后，它就出现在剧集里了。天哪，这对我的意义太重大了。所以这真的是一个诸如此类的宝藏。所以我确实想说，关于近景独白，它几乎成了它自己的一个独立存在，这些内容现在可以重见天日，我们可以有多个版本，而不会让人觉得，你知道的，我们以前有时间限制，只能挑一个。
I love that, especially as supporting cast. I feel like a lot of times our talking heads were cut for time. So I'm gonna look for all of them. I just, I'm delighted by that. Well, I wonder how many subscriptions to Peacock we just sold in this podcast today. I would think a lot.
我太喜欢这样了，特别是作为配角。我觉得很多时候我们的近景独白都是因为时间不够而被剪掉了。所以我打算把它们全都找出来。我真的，太为之高兴了。好吧，我在想我们今天在这个播客里究竟卖出了多少Peacock的订阅。我想有很多吧。
And I would think, Dave, it's all because of you. And we wanted to have you on today because you were doing a beautiful thing for the show. And we're so appreciative as fans of The Office. We're both fans. And we, this is not a sponsored episode. We don't get anything for this. I mean, we don't get money for this. I mean we don't
而且我觉得，戴夫，这全都是因为你。我们今天想邀请你来，是因为你在为这部剧做一件很美好的事。作为《办公室》的粉丝，我们非常感激。我们俩都是粉丝。而且，这不是一期赞助节目。我们从这上面什么也得不到。我是说，我们从这上面拿不到钱。我是说我们
get money for the episodes that air on Peacock. But what you have done here is a gift. It is a gift to fans. It is a beautiful thing. And it's just we're so excited that we get to talk about it and highlight it for that reason. Thank you. I'm excited for you guys to watch them. Like I am like just to see you know to discover. Applause to Dave and Rob and everyone editing the Superfans and putting them together and Claire and Dean. But Dave, before we say goodbye to you, we need to talk about something which we can't talk about. So I don't know how we're going to talk about it except that we got to go to the set of the paper. You were directing. You were directing. We can't say anything else really, but how fun to see you directing and we can't wait to have you on to talk about the paper for reals.
从在Peacock上播出的剧集里也拿不到钱。但你在这里所做的一切是一份礼物。它是送给粉丝的一份礼物。这是一件很美好的事。正因如此，我们能谈论它并重点介绍它，让我们感到无比兴奋。谢谢。我很期待你们去看它们。就像我一样，就是去看看，你知道的，去发现。向戴夫、罗宾以及所有剪辑爆迷版并将它们整合在一起的人致敬，还有克莱尔和迪恩。不过戴夫，在我们跟你道别之前，我们需要聊一件我们其实不能聊的事。所以我不知道我们要怎么聊这件事，除了我们去过《纸业公司》的片场。你在导演。你在导演。我们真的不能再多说什么了，但是看你当导演该有多好玩啊，我们迫不及待地想请你来聊聊真正的《纸业公司》。
Yes, I'm excited to talk about it. Can't say too much now. It was great seeing you guys. We have a lot of crew that carried over from the office. And Greg was so gracious to have us on set. That was crazy, though, just pulling up. And then the first person we see is Sergio. And then we walk a few steps. Then we walk a few steps, and then there's Kasha. Then we see Kelly Cantley in the hallway. And then there you are. I Then we see Kelly Cantley in the hallway. And then there you are.
是的，我很兴奋能聊聊这个。现在还不能说太多。见到你们太棒了。我们有许多工作人员是从《办公室》延续过来的。格雷グ也非常热情地邀请我们来到片场。不过那真的很疯狂，刚把车开到那儿。然后我们看到的第一个人是塞尔吉奥。接着我们走了几步。然后我们走了几步，接着是卡莎。我们在走廊里看到了凯利·坎特利。然后就是你。我 然后我们在走廊里看到了凯利·坎特利。然后就是你。
I mean, it just was, it was so special. Yeah. Yeah, it is really nice to see familiar faces. I mean, Veda. Yes, Veda. Samarney is there. Rusty. Rusty Mahmood.
我的意思是，那真的，真的是太特别了。对。对，看到熟悉的面孔真的很好。我是说，维达。是的，维达。萨马尼在那里。鲁斯蒂。鲁斯蒂·马哈茂德。
Mahmood is there. So there are a lot of familiar faces. And that's, it's always nice. We had such a great, great group of people on the show. We really did. Such a great crew. So it's nice. And there's a lot of great new people that I've been working with too.
马哈茂德也在那儿。所以有很多熟悉的面孔。而且那，总是很美好。我们在剧里有过那么棒、那么棒的一群人。我们真的有过。这么棒的工作人员。所以这感觉很好。而且我也一直在和很多非常棒的新人合作。
So it's, you know. That you will tell us about at some point. That's right. So we can bug them when the paper comes out for all the details on how they designed that set and did those props. Yeah. I will say it was really nice seeing you guys come in on the set. And just like, oh, and everybody, I mean, you guys got a huge round of applause
所以这，你知道的。这些你们以后会在某个时候告诉我们的。没错。所以当《纸业公司》播出时，我们可以去烦他们，打听他们是如何设计那个片场和制作那些道具的所有细节。是的。我得说，看到你们走进片场真的感觉很好。就像是，哦，每个人，我是说，你们获得了热烈的掌声
and everything. Everybody was just very, you know, just they know what you guys have done and what you guys have brought to, you know, television and this universe, this office universe. And, you know, it means a lot. You guys are royalty. Aw. Really. That's so nice.
以及各种欢呼。每个人都非常，你知道的，他们知道你们做过什么，知道你们给，你知道的，电视界以及这个宇宙、这个《办公室》宇宙带来了什么。而且，这意义重大。你们就是皇室。啊。真的。太好了。
I was afraid, honestly I knew you guys were coming I was like oh is it the cast is going to be intimidated like are they going to be you know I hope they're not like all super nervous you know. Aw. But they're pros everybody. They're lovely. I feel like I can reveal this one thing because I found it really charming, which is that we also got to tour the writer's space, which was really neat.
老实说，我之前很担心，我知道你们要来，我就想，哦，演员们会不会感到拘束，会不会觉得，你知道的，我希望他们不会超级紧张，你知道的。啊。但大家都是专业人士。都很可爱。我觉得我可以透露这一件事，因为我觉得它真的很有魅力，那就是我们也参观了编剧的工作区，那真的很整洁。
When I went into the writer's room and they had all the cards on the board, just like we had cards on the board. But then I looked over at the episode that you were shooting, and there were three photographs from the office, and they were shots of us in cars driving. And I asked about it, and Kelly said, oh yeah, that's because we have some driving shots coming up, and we were just looking at for research, how do you shoot in a car?
当我走进编剧室时，他们板子上贴满了卡片，就像我们以前板子上贴卡片一样。但接着我看了看你们正在拍摄的那一集，上面有三张来自《办公室》的照片，那是我们在车里开车的剧照。我问起了这事，凯利说，哦对，那是因为我们接下来有一些开车拍的镜头，我们只是在做研究，看看怎么在车里拍摄。
Yeah, and Greg was saying the lipstick cameras and you... Yeah, I'm the one who provided the pictures. Oh, of course. And I was, yeah. I took a picture of them. I did too. I was there. I was in one of them.
对，格雷格还说到了唇膏摄像机，还有你……对，照片是我提供的。哦，当然。我当时，是的。我拍了它们的照片。我也拍了。我当时就在那儿。其中一张里就有我。
Well, yeah, because we should, I think yours was probably Andy's Ancestry. Yes, it was me and Nellie. You and Nellie, and I had directed that one. So I had that one. And there was one of Michael and Daryl. Yeah, and that was another one I did. That was Employee Transfer. Those were ones I directed because I had, I remember just struggling,
哦，对，因为我们应该，我觉得你的那张可能来自《安迪的祖先》。是的，那张是我和内莉。你和内莉，那集是我执导的。所以我保留了那张。还有一张是迈克尔和达尔的。对，那也是我拍的另一张。那是《员工调动》。那些都是我执导的剧集，因为我记得自己当时很挣扎，
like how are we going to do the camera angles? Like what do we, you know, because you have to choose. You don't, you know, when you're shooting an interior car scene and you have the, what we call the lipstick cams, you can only get so many cameras in there. Yep. Right. So it's like, do you want the, you know, a raking shot? Do you want a single? What, you know, so this, we were just looking at these kinds of frames and to say like, hey, this is, you know, what we're going for. And I had a conversation with the DP afterwards
就像我们要怎么处理摄像机角度？我们要怎么做，你知道的，因为你得做出选择。你不能，你知道的，当你在拍车内场景，并且拥有我们所谓的唇膏摄像机时，你只能在里面塞下那么多摄像机。没错。对吧。所以就像是，你是想要，你知道的，一个斜角镜头？你想要单人镜头吗？你，你知道的，所以这个，我们只是在看这些类型的画面，然后说，嘿，这就是，你知道的，我们想要的效果。后来我和摄影指导（DP）谈过
because she wanted to show like the camera. She's like, well, we should see the cameras, you know, when we're outside the car. I'm like, nope. I's like, well, we should see the cameras, when we're outside the car. I'm like, nope. I'm like, whenever we did this on the show, we would not, that's the precedent. Whenever we, we would have these lipstick cams, but sometimes we would have, we would go film the actual car and you wouldn't see them.
因为她想展示摄像机。她说，好吧，我们在车外时应该能看到摄像机，你知道的。我说，不。我说，我们在车外时应该能看到摄像机。我说，不。我说，每当我们在剧中这样做时，我们都不会这样做，这是先例。每当我们在剧中，我们会有这些唇膏摄像机，但有时我们会去拍真正的汽车，而你是看不到它们的。
We didn't want to obscure the actor's faces. We just buy that these are very, very tiny cameras that are in there. And then we'd take, yeah. That's such a good point. So this is so interesting then because you are now on the paper preserving the look of the office because it's the documentary crew. It's the same documentary crew. So they will have shot it the same way.
我们不想遮挡演员的脸。我们只是默认这些是非常非常微小的摄像机藏在里面。然后我们会拍，是的。这真是个好观点。所以这非常有趣，因为你现在在《纸业公司》里保留了《办公室》的视觉风格，因为这是那个纪录片团队。是同一个纪录片团队。所以他们会用同样的方式拍摄。
There's still some new things that they can do. But yes, there are certain things that, you know, like this is the point is that it exists in this universe. We're not doing like enough. I mean, there are so many mockumentary shows out there right now. And, you know, that's one thing I'll say, Greg, you know, he kind of wanted to get back to basics with, you know, the style of the office and like, I don't want to have and feel like there's 15 cameras around, Yeah, right. And so, you know, and there have been a lot of, I think, important creative decisions on just, you know, everything from the casting to the set to the, you know, style of the show and what we're doing. So yeah.
他们仍然可以做一些新东西。但是是的，有些特定的事情，你知道的，比如这就是重点，它存在于这个宇宙中。我们没有做得太过分。我的意思是，现在外面有那么多伪纪录片剧集，而且，这就是我要说的，格雷格，你知道的，他某种程度上想回归本源，采用《办公室》的风格，比如，我不想让人觉得周围有15台摄像机，对吧。所以，你知道的，而且有很多，我认为非常重要的创意决策，仅仅是在，你知道的，从选角到布景，再到，你知道的，剧集的风格以及我们在做的事情上。所以是的。
Well, we're excited. We're excited to see it. Last question for you, Dave, before you leave. You had mentioned that you still have a bottle of champagne in your fridge from Aaron Sorkin. Yes. Will you tell that story? Oh my gosh. Well, one day we got a, Greg shared an email with us.
好吧，我们很兴奋。我们很兴奋能看到它。戴夫，在你离开之前最后一个问题。你曾提到你的冰箱里至今还放着一瓶艾伦·索尔金送的香槟。是的。你能讲讲那个故事吗？天哪。好吧，有一天我们收到了一封，格雷格给我们分享了一封电子邮件。
I guess Aaron Sorkin had written, Aaron Sorkin, you know, the great writer who's done, I mean, just a few good men, The West Wing, one of my favorite shows. He did The Newsroom, another amazing show. He had written Greg a letter and he just said how much he loved The Office, the writing, the cast, the editing. Do you remember? Greg printed it out and put it up at craft services.
我猜是艾伦·索尔金写的，艾伦·索尔金，你知道的，那位伟大的编剧，他创作过，我的意思是，仅仅是《好人寥寥》、《白宫风云》（我最喜欢的剧集之一）。他还创作了《新闻编辑室》，另一部精彩的剧集。他给格雷格写了一封信，信里盛赞了他有多么喜欢《办公室》、剧本、演员以及剪辑。你还记得吗？格雷格把它打印出来贴在了剧组的餐点供应处。
That wall that we had to walk past to get on the soundstage had, you know, people's wedding announcements, a baby photo of whoever had just had a baby photo of the, whoever had just had a baby and then this big, this letter from Aaron Sorkin in the middle. Yeah. So there's, and he had given Greg like a case of a Don Perignon. So I got a bottle and it's still in my fridge. How many years have you had that? I mean, how many years, 15 years? When did we get it?
我们去往摄影棚必须走过的那面墙上，贴着，你知道的，大家的结婚启事，刚生了孩子的谁的婴儿照片，还有正中间这封来自艾伦·索尔金的信。对。所以，这里有，而且他送了格雷格一箱唐培里侬香槟。所以我拿到了一瓶，它现在还静静地躺在我的冰箱里。这酒你在那儿放了多少年了？我是说，多少年了，15年？我们是什么时候拿到它的？
When did they get it? I don't know. A long time ago. When are you going to open it? I don't know. There were times where I wanted to and then other people are like, oh, no, no, no, you want to save that. It's so good.
他们是什么时候拿到它的？我不知道。很久以前了。你打算什么时候打开它？我不知道。有时候我想开，但其他人又会说，哦，不，不，不，你得把它留着。这酒太棒了。
Like, you don't want to just drink it on New Year's or do you? And I'm like, all right, just live it in the fridge. Maybe this year or next year. I'll make sure I drink it. Does anybody want to share? Yes. Come over. We'll come over for some Aaron Sorkin champagne.
就像，你不能就这么在新年时把它喝掉，对吧？然后我就想，好吧，那就让它继续待在冰箱里吧。也许今年或者明年。我一定得把它喝了。有人想分享一下吗？好啊。过来吧。我们会过去喝艾伦·索尔金的香槟。
Let's have some. We'll watch a super fan episode. How's that? Oh, yes. I love that. I love that. All right. Well, Dave, we love you so much.
来喝一杯吧。我们顺便看一集爆迷版。怎么样？哦，好啊。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。好吧。那戴夫，我们太爱你啦。
Thank you for being here today. I love you guys. Love you, Dave. Thank you. Thanks for having me. It's really, it's, I love your show. We're going to talk more about the Star Wars holiday special. No.
谢谢你今天来到这里。我也爱你们。爱你们，戴夫。谢谢。谢谢邀请我。这真的是，我很喜欢你们的节目。我们要多聊聊《星球大战假日特别篇》。不。
No. Oh man. But I love you guys. I love what you're doing. And yeah, I'm a fan. I'm a fan. Aw, thanks Dave. Thank you.
不。哦天哪。但我爱你们。我爱你们正在做的事。而且，是的，我是粉丝。我是个粉丝。噢，谢谢戴夫。谢谢。
Dave Rogers is the best. The best. Dave, thank you so much for being in studio with us today. We just love you. And we want to say thank you to Dave and his whole team for treating our show with such love and care. You can check out all of the Superfan episodes on Peacock. And we can't wait to get Dave's must watch list. I know.
戴夫·罗杰斯是最棒的。最棒的。戴夫，非常感谢你今天来到我们的录音室。我们太喜欢你了。我们要向戴夫和他的整个团队表达感谢，感谢他们带着如此多的爱与关怀来对待我们的节目。大家可以在Peacock上观看所有的爆迷版剧集。我们已经迫不及待地想看到戴夫的必看清单了。我懂的。
Thanks, everyone. We'll see you next week. Have a great one. Have a great one. Have a good one. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins, our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢大家。我们下周见。祝大家过得愉快。过得愉快。过得愉快。感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”是Odyssey的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，助理制片人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。“办公室女士”由克里斯·巴塞尔进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿演奏的“鲁珀特树”。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。